I'M GOING TO CALL SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION TO
ORDER AND WE HAPPEN TO HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENCE. SO BEFORE WE
GET TO OUR AGENDA, I'M GONNA ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROOM.
SENATORS. LAIRD HERE, LAD HERE,
SENATOR MIN. SENATOR WK WK
PRESENT. WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UM TODAY IS THE
FOURTH, UH OF THE HEARINGS OF
THE BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE ON THE
PROPOSED BUDGET THIS YEAR, AND
WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS IN FRONT OF
US. UH, THE FIRST ONE IS ON THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM. UH THE SECOND ONE IS ON
ATTENDANCE. RECOVERY OF THE
THIRD IS ON INSTRUCT CONTINUITY,
AND THE FOURTH IS THE LEARNING.
RECOVERY EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM. WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER THESE FOUR ITEMS
AND, UM, AS USUAL, I WILL JUDGE
HOW MANY PEOPLE THERE ARE HERE
ARE HERE TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S A
LIMITATION OF A MINUTE OR TWO OR
OR WHERE WE ARE, UH, ON THAT,
AND SO WITH NÓ AND LET ME JUST
REMIND EVERYBODY AT THE OUTSET.
UM SINCE WE ONLY ARE TAKING
TESTIMONY IN PERSON IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THAT'S LISTENING, UH,
THAT CANNOT BE PRESIDENT OUR
MEETING AND WISHES TO WEIGH IN
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY OF, UH,
SUBMITTING COMMENTS TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. UH, UH, OR TO THE
WEBSITE FOR THE COMMITTEE SO
THAT WE WANT TO HEAR, UH, WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING, EVEN IF YOU
CAN'T BE HERE TODAY. KNOW THAT
YOU CAN DO THAT, UH, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER ONE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE, THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM.
IT'S AN UPDATE, AND WE HAVE, UM
SABRINA AT ADAMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MICHAEL
FUNK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION EDGAR CABRAL FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOMEBODY
ELSE THAT WILL BE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF WE NEED IT, AND SO,
UH, BEGIN AND WE WILL GO IN THAT
ORDER. WE'LL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS, UM, OFFICE SO WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING,
MR CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SABRINA ADAMS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR BEFORE
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER SCHOOL
EDUCATION AND ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THE SIXTH GRADE,
BEGINNING IN THE 2020 THREE 24
SCHOOL YEAR, LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO OFFER
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAMS TO ALL LOW INCOME
STUDENTS, ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
WITH THE HIGHEST CONCENTRATIONS
OF THESE STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO OFFER EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL ELEMENTARY
STUDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES NOT PROPOSE ANY CHANGES TO
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES, PROGRAM FUNDING
OR ITS REQUIREMENTS AND SUSTAINS
THE ONGOING COMMITMENT OF 4
BILLION PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR. UM,
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS, AND I
CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIRMAN, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MICHAEL FUNK
. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
EXPANDED LEARNING DIVISION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND,
JUST FOR THE RECORD OF I'VE
GIVEN OVER 30 YEARS OF MY LIFE
TO EXPAND LEARNING 20 YEARS IN
THE BAY AREA. ACTUALLY
PARTNERING WITH SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED AND OAKLAND UNIFIED
OPERATING PROGRAMS, PARTNERING
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
FAMILIES AND HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING THE LAST 12
YEARS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND BEING PART OF THIS
INCREDIBLE EXPANSION OF EXPANDED
LEARNING STATEWIDE THROUGH THE
EL Ó P. SO IN HIS THIRD YEAR.
BEEN LEARNING UP TO HIS PROGRAM
HAS DRAMATICALLY INCREASED. THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITIES. I'VE HAD
INTERACTIONS WITH
SUPERINTENDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
. I'VE SPENT A LOT OF MY TIME
USUALLY WEEKLY TALKING WITH
SUPERINTENDENTS. THREE YEARS AGO
. IT WAS TYPICALLY A
SUPERINTENDENT, WHO WOULD SAY WE
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. WE'VE NEVER DONE
EXPANDED LEARNING. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT TO DO. AND IN THE PROCESS
OF COACHING AND DIALOGUE AND
WORKING WITH THEM AND STARTING
WITH WHAT THEIR FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS NEEDED AND DESERVED AS
OPPOSED TO STARTING WITH. WHAT
ARE THE BARRIERS? WHAT ARE THE
RULES? WE WERE ABLE TO FIND MANY
OF THESE SUPERINTENDENTS TO NOW
BECOME A HUGE PROPONENT OF THIS
PROGRAM AND THE FUNDING AND I'VE
I'VE HAD IT SAID TO ME THAT THIS
HAS BEEN THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
FUNDING FOR MY COMMUNITY THAT
I'VE SEEN IN MY CAREER IN
EDUCATION. I ACTUALLY HAVE
SEVERAL SUPERINTENDENTS THAT
HAVE SAID THAT NOT TOO LONG AGO
STAFF. FROM FINANCE LEO èC Dð
STATE BOARD WENT TO FOLSOM
CORDOVA UNIFIED THEY HAD NINE
SCHOOL SITES BEFORE THAT WERE
FUNDED BY THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAM. NOW
THEY HAVE 20 THREE SCHOOL SITES.
OFFERING. SERVICES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY REPORT THAT MANY OF THEIR
PARENTS HAVE FINALLY BEEN ABLE
TO STABILIZE THEIR WORK AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THEIR
FAMILIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SAFE PLACE FOR THEIR STUDENTS TO
GO EVERY DAY AFTER SCHOOL WHERE
TRANSPORTATION IS PROVIDED, AND
NOT ONLY IS IT JUST A SAFE PLACE
FOR THEM TO GO, BUT THEY REPORT
AH, A TRANSFORMATIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEIR CHILDREN
ARE GETTING EXPOSED TO NEW
OPPORTUNITIES, IDEAS AND
CARRYING ADULTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY. LAST SUMMER, I
VISITED FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHO HAS ONE OF THE MOST
ROBUST SUMMER PROGRAMS THAT I'VE
SEEN IN MY CAREER. I ASKED THEIR
SUPERINTENDENT, MR BOB NELSON,
TO TELL ME WHAT THE PROGRAM
MEANS TO HIM, AND HE WROTE ME
THIS MESSAGE. I THINK SOME OF
THE CRITICAL THINGS WHY IS SO
IMPORTANT? OR BEING ABLE TO FUND
THE BEST KID CENTRIC NONPROFITS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. PROVIDING
ECONOMIC VIABILITY FOR OUR TOWN
BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING SAFE A SAFE,
COMFORTABLE AND LOVING PLACE FOR
KIDS TO THRIVE WHERE THEIR
PARENTS HAVE THE FREEDOM TO STAY
WORKING. WE ARE ALSO CREATING A
NATURAL PIPELINE OF NEW TEACHERS
AND LEADERS FROM THE CLASSIFIED
STAFF AND COMMUNITY EDUCATORS
WHO ARE SERVING IN THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAM. IN OUR CASE
WHERE OUR STUDENTS ARE NOT
NATURALLY GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT PRIVILEGED KIDS HAVE WOULD
HAVE IN TERMS OF CAMPS OR
DISTANCE EXPERIENCING. WE CAN
PROVIDE THIS DIRECTLY USING
FUNDING. IT GIVES US THE
COMBINATION OF BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE ACADEMIC SUPPORT TO MAKE
UP FOR SOME LOST TIME IN THE
CLASSROOM, AS WELL AS JUST DOING
AMAZING THINGS THAT KEEP KIDS
COMING BACK TO BUCK THE TREND OF
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. IN AN
ENVIRONMENT OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. THIS PROGRAM IS
LARGELY PAYING FOR ITSELF. AND
THAT'S OF COURSE, SPEAKING TO
THEIR DISTRICT FINANCES, WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A REPORT FILED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. PRODUCED
BY WEST END THAT LOOKS AT OUR
EXPANDED LEARNING DATA OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT REPORTS
THAT CHILDREN WHO ATTEND THE
PROGRAM 60 DAYS OR MORE, WHICH,
BY THE WAY, IS A VAST MAJORITY
OF THE STUDENTS. UH THEIR SCHOOL
VARIES BY GRADE, BUT THEIR
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE. INCREASES
DRAMATICALLY. COMPARED TO
STUDENTS OF THE SAME DEMOGRAPHIC
THAT ATTAINED ATTEND THE SAME
SCHOOL. SO WE KNOW THAT IN MANY
CASES, CHILDREN WHO ARE DEEPLY
ENGAGED IN EXPANDED LEARNING
HAVE A DEEP RELATIONSHIP WITH
CARING ADULTS IN THAT PROGRAM
SOMETIMES COME TO SCHOOL JUST SO
THEY CAN GO TO THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM. FINALLY I'M NOT SURE
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE L Ó
WILL SAY TODAY, BUT IT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED. THAT THE MECHANISM FOR
FUNDING OPB ADJUSTED, POSSIBLY
BASED ON ACTUAL ATTENDANCE. AND
I WOULD OFFER THE FOLLOWING.
COMMENTS. MANY LE A ARE DOING
EXACTLY WHAT THE èC Dð
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE RECOMMENDED.
THEY ARE BLENDING AND BRAIDING
OTHER FUNDING WITH L Ó. SUCH AS
ACES 21ST CENTURY COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS. AND OTHER AND
PROGRAMS SO TO EXTRAPOLATE
ATTENDANCE, SIMPLY BASED ON OP
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE OF
THE BLENDED FUNDING THAT WE'RE
ENCOURAGING. SECONDLY THE
LEGISLATURE DID NOT GIVE èC Dð
AUTHORITY. TO CAPTURE
ATTENDANCE. BY DESIGN. èC Dð
WILL NOT èC Dð WILL LIKELY
CAPTURE ATTENDANCE IN THE FUTURE
AND WE'RE WORKING ON THAT. BUT
THE DATA IS NOT AVAILABLE NOW TO
MAKE THAT CALCULATION. AND
FINALLY PART OF THIS HEARING IS,
OF COURSE, ABOUT ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY. AND THE TRAILER BILL
ALSO ALLOWS FOR A TENNIS
RECOVERY TO BE PART OF EL Ó. IN
THE FUTURE. FUNDING AT THE LEVEL
OF CURRENT ATTENDANCE. IS NOT
ALLOW DOES NOT PROVIDE CAPACITY
FOR GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
STAFFING LEVEL TO ACCOMMODATE
FOR GROWTH. SO INCREASING
ATTENDANCE WILL BE NECESSARY FOR
THE NEW ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
COMPONENT. TO BE INCLUDED. MUCH
MORE TO SAY, BUT I'LL CONCLUDE
MY COMMENTS THERE AND BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND EVEN THOUGH A TENANT'S
RECOVERY UH UH. IT IS A PIECE OF
THIS. WE DO HAVE OUR NEXT
SEPARATE ITEM ON ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY, SO LET'S GO TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. THEY'LL
TURN IT ON. IF YOU JUST GET OUT
THERE, I, UH GOOD MORNING, EDGAR
CABRAL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE A
OFFICE. I'LL JUST KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF. I THINK, AS I
MENTIONED THERE IS NÓ SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL HERE IN, UH REGARDING E
Ó P OR THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM IN IN THIS
BUDGET, I THINK TO MR F COMMENTS
EARLIER ABOUT A PROPOSED
CHANGES. I THINK IN THE PAST, WE
HAVE, UH, SUGGESTED PROVI, UH,
RECOMMENDED THAT THE FUNDING IN
THE PROGRAM BE BASED ON ACTUAL
PARTICIPATION IN THE RATHER THAN
UH, RATHER THAN, UH, FUNDING,
WHICH CURRENTLY WORKS.
ESSENTIALLY IT'S ALL ATTENDANCE
FOR YOUR OF LOW INCOME, LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. ESSENTIALLY UM,
I THINK, UH, THERE IS A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THE PROGRAM. WE
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACTUALLY KNOW HOW
THE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT. A LOT
OF THE FUNDS CAN BE USED TO, FOR
EXAMPLE, BE PROVIDING A LOT OF
ENHANCED EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS. UM I THINK I WILL SEE
THAT OUR OFFICE HAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE VASTNESS OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT'S NECESSARILY IF
WE KNEW WHAT THOSE SPENDING WAS
THAT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE THE
KINDS OF EXPANDED LEARNING
ACTIVITIES THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
EXPECTED WHEN YOU FUNDED THIS
PROGRAM, SO WE DO THINK WHETHER
YOU MAKE CHANGES TO THE POLICY
AT ALL. WE DO THINK GETTING
BETTER INFORMATION ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAMS. HOW THOSE FUNDS
ARE BEING SPENT IS IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS. I'M GONNA BEGIN WITH
A COUPLE AND THEN I'LL I'LL GIVE
MY CO, UH COLLEAGUES. HOPEFULLY
BY THEN AAA CHANCE TO, UH UM,
FOLLOW UP AND HE I ESSENTIALLY
HAVE TWO QUESTIONS AND TH THIS
PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED SO THAT
THERE'S BASICALLY TWO TIERS
BASED ON 75% PARTICIPATION OR
MORE AND AS WE SEE WHEN WE GET
TO ATTENDANCE LATER, THE THING
THAT IS SAVED SOME OF THE, UH
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES HAS
BEEN THE ROLLING THREE YEAR UH
OR BEING ABLE TO PICK BECAUSE IT
SOFTENS THE IMMEDIATE IMPACTS.
BUT HERE, UH, IT'S 75% AND IF
YOU DROP BELOW 75% YOU MEET WE
GO FROM 2700 AND $50, A STUDENT
TO $1800 A STUDENT, AND IT MIGHT
BE ONE STUDENT BELOW THE 75% AND
WE ARE ABOUT TO ADD THE, UM THE
PRE-KINDERGARTEN AND KINDER INTO
THE REPUTATIONS, WHICH COULD
WELD CHANGE MANY DISTRICTS AND
KNOCK THEM BETWEEN THE TIERS.
AND SO MY QUESTION WAS, IS
WHETHER THERE'S BEEN ANY
CONSIDERATION. AH FOR ANYTHING
THAT MIGHT SOFTEN THE IMMEDIATE
IMPACT OF KNOCKING PEOPLE
DRAMATICALLY RIGHT AS THE
NUMBERS COME IN THAT SHOW WHERE
THEY ARE, AND I DON'T KNOW. UH,
MAYBE WE'LL START WITH F AND LET
EVERYBODY SEE IF THEY WISH TO
TAKE A CRACK AT THAT. SABRINA
ADAMS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY CHANGES TO
THE CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE. UM
SO YEAH, WELL, NÓ, THAT'S
ACTUALLY MY QUESTION IS IN MANY
WAYS. WHY IF IT'S GONNA SUDDENLY
KNOCK A BUNCH OF PEOPLE AND
WHETHER THERE'S ANY
CONTEMPLATION OF SOFTENING THAT
BLOW IF THERE'S BUNCHES OF
CHANGES BECAUSE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COME INTO THE COUNTING,
BUT I I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
ANSWER THAT YOU DON'T
CONTEMPLATE THAT, UH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO
THERE'S WE'VE BEEN IN SOME
CONVERSATION WITH ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION STAFF, AND THERE IS A
CURRENT BILL A B 2112. THAT
CALLS FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONVENE A WORK GROUP THAT
INCLUDES UM VARIOUS OF
LEADERSHIP FROM ACROSS THE STATE
, INCLUDING THE LEGISLATURE OF
PARENTS, FAMILIES, SCHOOL
DISTRICT PEOPLE, COMMUNITY BASED
PARTNERS. TO CONVENE THAT WORK
GROUP OR USE EXISTING WORK
GROUPS TO ADDRESS SEVERAL ITEMS
RELATED TO AND REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY I THINK IT'S
NOVEMBER 20 25 AND ONE OF THE
ITEMS ON THAT LIST IS A
STABILIZATION OF RATE TWO. WHICH
IS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
BELOW 75. SO WE HAVEN'T DUG INTO
THE BASICALLY UNDER THIS BUDGET.
UNDER THIS BUDGET, THERE IS NÓ.
THAT'S THE POINT STARTS. UH UH,
JULY 1ST, AND WE WOULD BE
CONVENING A GROUP WHEN IT'S WAY
AFTER THERE'S BEEN A BIG CHANGE
IN A BUMP IN AND PEOPLE MIGHT
HAVE REALLY CHANGED. LOST FON
DUE TO THAT. WE? I WOULD CONCUR.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. OK DO
DOES THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
HAVE A COMMENT ON THIS? UM YES,
I THINK WE DO AGREE. THIS IS
PART OF THE PROGRAM THAT IS THAT
I THINK CAN CAN CREATE A LACK OF
STABILITY FOR DISTRICTS. I MEAN,
WE ARE RECOMMENDED AAA
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
HOW YOU FUND IT WHERE YOU'RE
JUST FUNDING BASED ON, UH, NOT
HAVING THE TWO TIERED STRUCTURE
ONE TIER. ANOTHER OPTION IS JUST
TO ACTUALLY JUST PICK A NUMBER
FOR THE SECOND TIER. RIGHT? I. I
THINK WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENED ALSO
IS WHAT IS IT? IT JUST IT'S NOT
JUST DOWN, BUT ALSO UP. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, WE HAD ONE YEAR WHERE,
UM YOU KNOW, WE ALWAYS USING THE
PRIOR YEAR DATA. SO WE HAD THE
INITIAL RATE THAN THE PRIOR
YEAR. DATA ATTENDANCE WENT DOWN
A LOT. UM SO THAT ACTUALLY FREED
UP FUNDING. UH THE TIER ONE COST
LESS SO THE TIER TWO RATE WENT
UP AND THEN WHEN ATTENDANCE GOES
BACK UP, THEN THERE'S NOT AS
MUCH MONEY LEFT FOR TIER TWO
TIER TWO IS SORT OF LIKE YOU
BACK INTO WHATEVER IS LEFT UNDER
THE PROGRAM, SO ANOTHER OPTION
IS JUST TO SET A NUMBER AND HAVE
THAT BUILT IN AND TO HAVE IT,
FOR EXAMPLE, CREATING A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN WHAT TIER
ONE AND TIER TWO ARE CONSIDERING
THAT THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS. STUDYING THAT
STATUTE THAT WOULD CREATE LESS
FOR THE STATE LESS
PREDICTABILITY THAT IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO COST EXACTLY 4 BILLION,
BUT FOR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT
CREATES A LOT MORE
PREDICTABILITY. THAT DOESN'T
ADDRESS. I THINK YOUR CONCERN,
THOUGH, OF WHAT ABOUT FOLKS WHO
ARE IN AND OUT OF THE THRESHOLD.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE. IT
CHANGES NOT ONLY THEIR RATES BUT
ALSO THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM FOR THEM. SOMEBODY
STEPPED TO THE PODIUM. BUT LET
ME ASK YOU FIRST. ARE YOU FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. SO IF
YOU'RE BACKING UP YOUR PERSON
HERE, WHY DON'T YOU COME AND SIT
DOWN BEFORE? SUDDENLY EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN THE AUDIENCE
FEELS ENTITLED TO STAND AT THE
PODIUM. YOUR SIDE. I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SCHOOL FISCAL
SERVICES DIVISION, AND WE
ALLOCATE THE ELOP FUNDING.
CURRENT LAW. I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
ON UH, WHAT'S MORE, YOU'RE CLOSE
ENOUGH ONE OR THE OTHER, UM
ELIZABETH DIÆN WITH THE DIRECT,
UM, THE DIRECTOR FOR THE SCHOOL
FISCAL SERVICES DIVISION AT èC
Dð E, AND WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING E EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM FUNDING.
CURRENT LAW DOES PROVIDE A THREE
YEAR HOLD HARMLESS TO PREVENT
FROM DROPPING FROM WEIGHT RUN TO
WEIGHT. TWO. SO THERE'S ALREADY
BUILT IN PROTECTION. THAT WASN'T
EVIDENT IN OUR AGENDA FOR ANY OF
THE COMMENTS THUS FAR, IT JUST
STARTED. THIS 2223 IS THE FIRST
FISCAL YEAR. UM SO EXCUSE ME FOR
HAVING TO ASK, SINCE I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS OR I'M JUST
HEARING ABOUT IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME. IS THAT IN STATUTE, OR IS
THAT OK? I CAN PROVIDE YOU WITH
A CITATION NÓ. I WOULD LOVE TO
KNOW THAT BECAUSE THAT'S VERY
RELEVANT, GIVEN THE FACT THAT
NUMBERS ARE GONNA CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY. UM THEN LET ME ASK
MY SECOND QUESTION, WHICH IS
RELATED TO THE FIRST AND I KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WAS
REQUIRED. TO DO DATA COLLECTION
OR HAVE A REPORT ON THIS WHICH,
OF COURSE, THEN IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE ISSUE OF
THE TEARS AND EVERYTHING IS
BASED ON THE DATA COLLECTION. UM
HAVE THERE BEEN PROBLEMS OR UH
UH, UH, IN COLLECTING THE
APPROPRIATE DATA TO ALLOW THE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE BETWEEN THE
TIERS. AND I DON'T KNOW WHO FROM
THE I. I'M HAPPY TO COMMENT ON
THAT JUST TO TAKE THAT. SO LET
ME JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO CLARIFY
WHAT DATA IS REQUIRED. HER
EDUCATION CODE. BY STATUTE, CDE
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
ACTUAL LE A EXPENDITURES AND YOU
HAVEN'T SAT THROUGH A HEARING
BEFORE. UH UH, BECAUSE I HAD A
CAMPAIGN AGAINST ACRONYMS. AND
UH UH, YOU STARTED LAUNCHING
INTO THEM AND SO AND IT WAS A
PERSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION LAST YEAR THAT USED
FOUR ACRONYMS IN ONE SENTENCE
THAT CAUSED ME TO FINALLY SAY OK
, THAT'S IT. UH UH SO THAT
EVERYBODY CAN UNDERSTAND. SO, UH
UH. CAUGHT HIMSELF AND, UH UH,
DEFINED THE ACRONYM BEFORE HE
GOT TOO FAR INTO IT. SO YOU'RE
FINE. I DON'T THINK THAT'LL
HAPPEN. GOING FORWARD. JUST BE
AWARE BASED ON THE STATUTE. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. VERY GOOD HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO ELECT TO COLLECT
FROM LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
EXPENDITURES FOR THE 2122 AND
2220 THREE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM ON AFTER
JUNE 30TH OF THIS YEAR 2024. BUT
THERE WAS ONE REPORT YOU HAD TO
SUBMIT BY FEBRUARY 1ST. I'LL GET
THERE. LET ME JUST WANNA. I
THOUGHT YOU HAD ENDED. I'M SORRY
WE'RE GOING SO WE HAVE THE
INSTRUMENT. PREPARED READY TO
SEND RIGHT AFTER JUNE 30TH 2024
TO GET THE EXPENDITURE DATA. THE
REPORT YOU'RE REFERRING TO WAS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTERS REPORT. ON IF THEY HAVE
THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS. THEY
CONTRACT WITH PROVIDING PROGRAMS
TO TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS. OFF SITE
OFF OF A SCHOOL CAMPUS. THAT WAS
THE REPORT THAT ST WAS DUE
FEBRUARY 1ST. THERE WERE SOME
COMPLICATIONS GETTING THE DATA
FROM THE DISTRICTS. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT AFTER CONFERRING UH,
THE REPORT WAS FINALIZED THIS
WEEK AND WE EXPECT IT TO BE
PUBLISHED ON THE WEBSITE TODAY
OR TOMORROW. THIS IS THE ONE
THAT WAS DUE BY FEBRUARY. THAT
IS CORRECT. JUST CHECKING. THAT
IS CORRECT, OK? THEN, AND I
WOULD I MAY 1 MORE THING. SO I
THINK THE DATA THAT MIGHT BE
MORE INTERESTING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF TIER ONE TIER TWO
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS. IS ACTUALLY
PART OF, UH, A CURRENT BILL AB
1113. WHICH IS GIVING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AUTHORITY TO COLLECT.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO STUDENTS IN
L INTO CAL BETS. SO WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
TO PUT THAT INTO PLACE. AND AS A
REFRESHER. THE EXPEND LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM HAS TWO
REQUIREMENTS FOR A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. TO OFFER.
THE PROGRAM, AND THAT'S DEFINED
IN CODE AS TO USE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
EFFECTIVE METHODS TO MAKE SURE
FAMILIES ARE AWARE THAT THEY
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND THE
SECOND IS TO PROVIDE ACCESS. AND
PROVIDING ACCESS IS DEFINED IN
EDUCATION CODE AS A SIGNED
ENROLLMENT FORM BY A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN FOR THE STUDENT TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM. SO THIS
BILL IS LOOKING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO ACTUALLY CAPTURE
HOW MANY STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED ACCESS IN THE PROGRAM
AND HAVE THAT AS PART OF CAL
BEDS. SO THAT IS IN PROCESS. UM
I THINK ONE THING TO SAY IS THAT
FOR A REFRESHER COMING THE OTHER
WAY, THE REASON THE REPORT WAS
DUE ON FEBRUARY, 1ST WAS SO WHEN
WE HAD A HEARING ON APRIL 4TH,
WE WOULD HAVE FULL BENEFIT OF
THAT REPORT AND HAVE THE ABILITY
TO TALK ABOUT IT HERE. AND SO I
THINK THAT, UH UH, WE WOULD
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE OUR
STAFF REVIEW THAT REPORT ONCE
IT'S POSTED AND DECIDE IF THERE
WERE QUESTIONS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO VEST HERE WITH
EVERYBODY PRESENT THAT WE UH,
UH, ADDRESS THEM TO YOU SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
JUST HAVE A FULL UNDERSTANDING
BEFORE WE GET TO MAKING A
DECISION. FULLY UNDERSTAND AND
WILLING TO COME BACK. AT AT YOUR
REQUEST, OK, ANY OTHER COMMENTS
ON THAT BEFORE I MOVE TO SENATOR
WILK? SEEING NONE. UH, YOU'VE
BEEN VERY PATIENT. THANK YOU.
WELL ACTUALLY, YOUR SECOND
QUESTION WAS A QUESTION THAT I
WANTED TO ASK, BECAUSE IT'S KIND
OF HARD TO HAVE A HEARING WHEN
YOU HAVE NÓ INFORMATION. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU ASKING THAT AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
REPORT. THANK YOU. AND THEN, UM,
I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS, BUT I'LL MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT ON ON THIS ITEM,
WHICH IS THAT, UM, I WOULD HOPE
THAT IF THERE WAS ANYTHING THAT
THE DISCLOSURE THAT THERE'S A
THREE YEAR HOLD HARMLESS WAS NEW
THAT THAT UP TO THAT I WAS
FEELING LIKE I WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU WOULD LISTEN TO THE
DISCUSSION WE HAD AND DECIDE
WHEN YOU COME BACK WITH THE MAY
REVISE. IF THERE'S ANY
ADJUSTMENTS THAT NEED TO BE MADE
IN THE PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE AND
WHILE THERE MIGHT BE AN
IMMEDIATE DISRUPTION THAT IS
PRESENT PREVENTED BY THE HOLD
HARMLESS, IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THAT THERE WOULD BE THE
STATISTICS THAT SHOW THAT
THERE'S A DISRUPTION ON THE WAY
JUST THAT THERE'S A HOLD
HARMLESS AND THAT THAT MIGHT
CAUSE A REASON TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND LOOK TO SEE IF THERE'S
SOME ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE SHOULD
MAKE IN THE PROGRAM AS PART OF
THE BUDGET AND I, I THINK WE
WOULD JUST STIPULATE TO THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A VERY VALUABLE
PROGRAM AND THERE IS A THING IN
OUR AGENDA PACK LATER ON ABOUT
SORT OF THE Tð Kò AND KINDER
COUNTING AND THE VALUE OF THE
PROGRAMS AND GETTING PEOPLE. UH
UH IN AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT
THERE, BUT IT ALSO REFLECTS ON
THIS ITEM, BECAUSE IF PEOPLE
AREN'T COUNTED RIGHT AND, UH,
ARE BEING STIMULATED IN A GOOD
WAY BY THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
REFLECTS ON THIS AS WELL, SO
ANYWAY, I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND, UH UH, AND, UM,
JUST, UH, WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
HOPE YOU WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THIS DISCUSSION IN CASE THERE'S
ANY ADJUSTMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE HEADED INTO THE MAY REVISE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO, WHICH IS ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY, AND WE HAVE ALEX CHOP
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND SITTING IN FOR ERIN ORIA
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IS ELIZABETH DIÆN, WHO'S ALSO UP
HERE AND PLEASE SEND OUR GOOD
WISHES TO MR AREDIA BECAUSE HE'S
ABSENT FOR A VERY GOOD REASON.
A. AND THEN WE HAVE, UH, UH,
MICHAEL FARRIS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. SO
UH, WITH THAT, LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR, SENATOR WILK,
ALEX CHOP WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. UH SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
AND ATTENDANCE RECOVERY PROPOSAL
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE ONE
INCREASED INSTRUCTIONAL OPTIONS
FOR STUDENTS WHEN THEY ARE
UNABLE TO FULLY PARTICIPATE IN
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION FOR LIMITED PERIODS,
UH OR ARE ABSENT FROM SCHOOL AND
THEN TWO STREAMLINED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO BETTER
SUPPORT STUDENTS. RECOVER
ATTENDANCE BASED APPORTIONMENT.
UH, FUNDING WHEN STUDENTS DO
MISS SCHOOL? UH SO I'LL PROVIDE.
YOU KNOW SOME MORE DETAIL ON THE
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY PART OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT MY COLLEAGUES WILL
SPEAK MORE ABOUT INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY IN THE FOLLOWING, UH,
PANEL. UH, SO AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
STREAMLINED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUPILS TO MAKE UP LOST, UH,
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AND OFFSET
ABSENCES, INCLUDING FOR CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND FOR LE, A S¼ TO
RECOVER A PORTION BASED
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING BASED ON
ATTENDANCE. UH, SO THE PROPOSAL
IS VOLUNTARY. UH, LE S¼ CAN
CHOOSE TO IMPLEMENT ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS, UH, STUDENTS
CAN CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THEM. WOULD BE ABLE TO GENERATE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE IN 15
MINUTE INCREMENTS IN ORDER TO
RECOVER UP TO 15 DAYS OF
ATTENDANCE PER STUDENT, UH,
PROVIDED THAT CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET. SO THESE INCLUDE
PROVIDING INSTRUCTIONAL CONTENT
THAT IS SUBSTANTIALLY EQUIVALENT
TO WHAT THE STUDENT WOULD HAVE
RECEIVED AS PART OF THEIR
REGULAR CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM, HAVING
INSTRUCTION PROVIDED UNDER THE
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
CERTIFICATED STAFF AND THEN
MEETING 20 TO 1, STUDENT TEACHER
RATIOS, UM AND 10 TO 1 RATIOS
FOR KINDERGARTEN AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. UH,
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL, S¼, UM,
COULD OFFER ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROGRAMS BEFORE OR AFTER SCHOOL,
UH, ON THE WEEKEND DURING
INTERCESSION PERIODS, AND THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
SATURDAY SCHOOL, UH OR EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS,
UM, TO DELIVER INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS, UM, ELECTING TO
PARTICIPATE, UH, THAT CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS HAVING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH, WE'LL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. IT TURNS ON AFTER
YOU PRESS THE BUTTON. IT'S ON.
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR. THERE'S NOT A RED LIGHT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM ELIZABETH DEERS, DIRECTOR
FOR THE SCHOOL FISCAL SERVICES
DIVISION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION
TONY THURMOND. èC Dð E
APPRECIATES THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
CHALLENGES LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES HAVE FACED COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE IMPACT
LOW ATTENDANCE RATES HAVE HAD ON
LEARNING LOSS, CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND FUNDING IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS SINCE THE
PANDEMIC, THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE CHANGES AND
THE INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AND
ATTENDANCE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS, AREAS THAT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE HAD TO
IMPLEMENT WITH LITTLE TO NÓ
PLANNING TIME. SINCE THE
PROPOSAL ADDS A NEW MESSAGE TO
GENERATE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WILL NEED ENOUGH TIME
TO UNDERSTAND THE REQUIREMENTS
AND UPDATE THEIR INTERNAL
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
ATTENDANCE SOFTWARE SYSTEMS.
WE'VE HAD INITIAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH STUDENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
VENDORS THAT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES USE FOR ATTENDANCE
TRACKING AND REPORTING, AND IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER OR NOT THE
CHANGE IS REQUIRED BY THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE IMPLEMENT IN
THE UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR, BOTH
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
COMPLIANCE MONITORING AFTER THE
FACT THROUGH THE ANNUAL AUDIT
PROCESS. WITHOUT SUFFICIENT TIME
TO PREPARE FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES MAY
STRUGGLE TO ADOPT COMPLIANT
PROGRAMS AND, AS A RESULT FACED
AN AUDIT PENALTY DURING THE
ANNUAL AUDIT OR SIMPLY BE UNABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM IN THE
24 AND 25 SCHOOL YEAR. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON THESE PROPOSALS
AS THE BUDGET PROCESS CONTINUES,
AND THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS,
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL MOVE TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WELCOME.
AH, GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL A WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. UH, SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL A MORE SIGNIFICANTLY,
UH, GIVEN THE CURRENT BUDGET
SITUATION, WE THINK THE STATE
LIKELY CANNOT SUPPORT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS. UH, WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE
ISN'T ANY FUNDING INCLUDED IN
THE IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS
PROPOSAL, THOUGH, AS PROPOSED IT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND WOULD
HAVE ASSOCIATED COSTS SINCE IT
ALLOWS, UM LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND TO GENERATE FOR
ATTENDANCE FOR FUNDING PURPOSES.
UH, WE DON'T HAVE OUR OWN
ESTIMATES OF THE PROPOSAL, BUT
WE EXPECT THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE STATE. BUT
EVEN IN THE SHORT TERM, UH,
DISTRICTS THAT ARE FUNDED ON THE
CURRENT YEAR LEVELS OF
ATTENDANCE AS OPPOSED TO THEIR,
UH PRIOR YEAR THREE YEAR PRIOR
YOUR AVERAGE WOULD, UH, SEE
FUNDING INCREASES IMMEDIATELY TO
THE EXTENT THAT THEY OPERATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND HAVE STUDENTS
PARTICIPATE. UH, ALSO FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS, SINCE ALL
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDED, UM UNDER CURRENT YEAR
LEVELS OF ATTENDANCE, THEY WOULD
SEE, UM INCREASES IMMEDIATELY IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AS WELL. A
RELATED CONCERN IS THAT ALTHOUGH
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE SPECIFIES
THAT THE INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL
IS TO HAVE STUDENTS RECOVER
ATTENDANCE FOR DAYS THAT THEY
WERE ABSENT, UH AND THAT
STUDENTS CANNOT GENERATE MORE
THAN 15 DAYS OF ATTENDANCE TO
PARTICIPATION IN THESE PROGRAMS.
WE DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT ACTUALLY LIMITS
THE AMOUNT OF ATTENDANCE THAT
STUDENTS CAN GENERATE THE, UH,
LIMITED BY THEIR ACTUAL ABSENCES
THAT THEY'VE HAD DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR. WE THINK THAT THIS
CREATES THE POTENTIAL FOR
STUDENTS TO GENERATE, UH MORE
THAN 100 AND 80 DAYS OF
ATTENDANCE THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
YEAR. UH, FOR EXAMPLE, A STUDENT
CAN ATTEND FOR 100 IN SCHOOL FOR
100 AND 70 DAYS PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM FOR ABOUT 15 DAYS
AND BE CREDITED WITH 100 AND 85
DAYS OF ATTENDANCE, EVEN THOUGH
THE SCHOOL YEAR IS ONLY 100 AND
80 DAYS. UH, SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
ADOPTING THIS PROPOSAL, UH,
WE'RE JUST RECOMMENDING THAT THE
STUDENTS PARTI, UM, ATTENDANCE
THAT CAN BE GENERATED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE LIMITED TO
THEIR ACTUAL ABSENCES. UM WE
ALSO HAVE A FEW OTHER IMPLEMENT,
UH, IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT
WE LIKE TO RAISE, UH, WHICH
START ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
SEVEN OF THE AGENDA. ONE ISSUE
IS THAT THE PROPOSAL ESSENTIALLY
CREATES TWO ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROGRAMS WITH DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS. SO UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS, NEW
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY PROGRAMS
WOULD OPERATE BEFORE OR AFTER
SCHOOL AND DURING INTER SESSIONS
, WHILE THE EXISTING ALLOWABLE
SATURDAY SCHOOL WITH OUR PRE ON
THE WEEKENDS, UH, FOR EXAMPLE,
SATURDAY SCHOOL MAKEUP CLASSES
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE ANY CAP ON
THE NUMBER OF DAYS OF ATTENDANCE
OF STUDENT CAN GENERATE
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE 15 DAY. UH,
AND THE, UM CURRENT SATURDAY
SCHOOL PROGRAM ALSO DOES NOT
HAVE ANY COMPARABLE STUDENT TO
TEACHER RATIO REQUIREMENT THAT
IS PROPOSED FOR THE THINNESS
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. UH, WE
RECOMMEND PROVIDING A MORE
CONSISTENT SET OF STANDARDS SUCH
AS REALIGNING CURRENT SATURDAY
SCHOOL REQUIREMENTS WITH THE
PROPOSED ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROGRAMS. REQUIREMENTS ARE
CONSOLIDATE BOTH INTO ONE
PROGRAM. UH SECONDLY, WE'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, UM, THE
OVERLAP ATTENDANCE, RECOVERY AND
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT OPERATE
BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL AND
DURING INTERCESSIONS, SUCH AS
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM, WHICH THE
, UH STAFF ANALYSIS REFERENCES,
UH, WHERE DISTRICTS COULD USE
THEIR EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROGRAMS, UM, GIVEN THAT
STUDENTS WOULD GENERATE FUNDING
TO THEIR PARTICIPATION IN TENANT
RECOVERY, WE DON'T SEE THE NEED
FOR DISTRICTS TO USE THEIR EP,
OR EXPAND LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM FUNDING. FOR, UH,
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY. UH, THE
LAST I'LL HIGHLIGHT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES, UH, IN
DECIDING THE TYPE OF INSTRUCTION
THAT WILL BE PROVIDED THROUGH
THEIR ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
PROGRAMS, THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER SETTING MORE
SPECIFIC EXPECTATIONS FOR
INSTRUCTION PROVIDED IN THESE
PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DIRECT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO FOCUS
THEIR BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND HELPING THEM KEEP
UP WITH THEIR, UH, EXISTING, UH,
COURSE WORK WELL. INTERCESSION
INSTRUCTION COULD PRIORITIZE
CREDIT RECOVERY. IN DECIDING
LEVEL SPECIFICITY SPECI SPECIFIC
SPECIFICITY. THAT'S A HARD WORD.
UH, HOWEVER, THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT TO WEIGH THE BENEFITS
OF THE ACRONYM FOR A SPECIFIC UH
I'M SO GLAD YOU'VE DECIDED TO
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, MR.
UH, YOU WON'T WANT TO WAY THAT
KIND OF TRADE OFFS OF, UH,
HAVING SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS, UM
, WITH LOTS OF FLEXIBILITY THAT
MAY REDUCE THE ADOPTION OF THESE
PROGRAMS. UM, THOSE CONCLUDES
OUR COMMENTS THAT YOU ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UH, I HAVE
A FEW QUESTIONS AND THEY GET TO
SOME OF THE I ISSUES THAT CAME
UP AND I WAS GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AGREED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. THERE'S NÓ MONEY IN
THIS BEFORE I DECLARE IT AS A
FACT. UH BUT IT IT'S I WONDERED
IF YOU HAD CALCULATED THE COST
FOR THIS PROGRAM TO KNOW HOW
MUCH IT WILL COST DISTRICTS TO
DO THIS AND WHETHER YOU AGREE
THAT THERE'S REALLY NÓ MONEY
PROVIDED FOR IT ONCE IT KICKS IN
JULY, 1ST IF THIS WAS APPROVED,
UH, THERE'S NÓ ADDITIONAL
FUNDING PROVIDED WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM, AND WE DO
NOT HAVE A SPECIFIC ESTIMATE AT
THE CURRENT TIME. AS TO ANY
POTENTIAL FUTURE COSTS. JUST FOR
THE RECORD, THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL. YOU KNOW, AND THEN
THERE'S UM UM, WE HAVE AN AGENDA
PACKET. A, UH, A STORY OF A
FAMILY FROM, UM SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY THAT WAS REFERENCED IN
CALMATTERS ON ON HOW THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN A
LIFESAVER AND PROBABLY COST THAT
KID ONE OF THOSE KIDS TO COME
BACK TO SCHOOL. IN THE WAY THEY
WEREN'T AND IT IT IT IT APPEARS
THAT THAT MIGHT NOT BE A
CALCULATED IN THIS. HOW HOW DOES
IT RELATE? SORT OF IF PEOPLE ARE
IN AN AFTER SCHOOL AND WH
WHETHER THAT FACTORS INTO WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING FOR ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY? SO I THINK I WOULD
MAYBE REITERATE THE OVERALL
INTENT OF THE PROPOSAL JUST, YOU
KNOW, BE ABLE TO PROVIDE, UM YOU
KNOW MORE OPTIONS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. UH, YOU
KNOW, TO PROVIDE THIS
INSTRUCTION TO STUDENTS TO
RECOVER. UM THE YOU KNOW,
RECOVER THAT ATTENDANCE FUNDING.
AS FAR AS THE INTERACTION WITH
ANY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS. UH,
WE'RE NOT PROPOSING ANY ANY
CHANGES RIGHT TO ANY SORT OF
EXTENDED LEARNING, UM, PROGRAMS
OR OR SATURDAY SCHOOL. UM I, I
THINK I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ABILITY UNDER THIS PROGRAM TO,
UH RECOVER, UH, ATTENDANCE IN 15
MINUTE INCREMENTS. UM COULD
PROVIDE, UH, ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. UM, SHOULD
YOU KNOW THEY THEY, UH YOU KNOW,
WANT TO PROVIDE, YOU KNOW,
INSTRUCTION KIND OF CORE
INSTRUCTION AS REQUIRED UNDER
THIS PROGRAM DURING AFTER SCHOOL
. UM, WHILE ALSO, YOU KNOW, BE
ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, BEING ABLE TO
STILL OFFER THOSE YOU KNOW,
EXTENDED LEARNING PROGRAMS AFTER
SCHOOL, UM, YOU KNOW, WITHOUT
SORT OF MISSING IN MY LIFE
CONSIDERED MYSELF VERY SCHOOLED.
I DO NOT KNOW. UH IF SCHOOLS NOW
RECORD ATTENDANCE IN 15 MINUTE
IT'S FOR EVEN AFTER SCHOOL AND
OTHER STUFF AND REPORT IT. IS
THAT DONE ALREADY, SO YOU OR IS
THAT NEW IN THIS? UH I DON'T
BELIEVE SO I WOULD DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT. IT IS RIGHT. I'M
SORRY. I COULDN'T HEAR WHAT YOU
SAID. IT IS NEW, OK, THAT THAT
ALL I CAN SAY IS TO SAVE ABOUT
15 PEOPLE WALKING TO THE
MICROPHONE DURING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. THAT IS AN ADDITIONAL
COST. THAT IS NOT ACCOUNTED FOR.
UH UH, IT APPEARS DOES THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAVE ANY
COMMENT? SO EXCHANGES WE'VE JUST
BEEN HAVING. I CAN JUST COMMENTS
RELATED TO EXPANDED LEARNING. I
THINK PART OF THE QUESTION, I
THINK SEEMS TO BE YOU KNOW, I. I
THINK MR FENS POINT EARLIER, THE
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM IS NOT
GROWING. IT'S A $4 BILLION
AMOUNT. SO IF THAT SPENDING HAS
ALREADY BEEN ACCOUNTED FOR
DISTRICTS ALREADY HAVE PLANS TO
SPEND THAT MONEY TO DO WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING WITH
THIS FLEXIBILITY MEANS YOU'RE
GONNA CHANGE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH YOUR EXISTING EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAM AND SHIFT THAT
FUNDING TO THIS ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY PROGRAM. UM NOW, I I'M
NOT SURE, I THINK BASED ON SOME
OF THE MOST RECENT SPENDING THAT
THERE MIGHT STILL BE DISTRICTS
WHO ARE NOT SPENDING ALL OF
THEIR ONGOING ALLOCATIONS. AND
SO THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO THEN
DIRECT SOME OF THAT FUNDING TO
THIS PURPOSE, BUT UH, JUST AGAIN
TO, UH, I. I DON'T THINK WE
THINK THIS IS A NECESSARY
COMPONENT OF IT. ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY BY DEFINITION INCREASES
YOUR A Dð. SO YOU'RE GONNA GET
MORE FUNDING. OR FOR DOING THIS?
UM SO WHY WE NEED TO SAY USE,
EXPANDED LEARNING FUNDING AS
WELL. WE DON'T THINK THAT'S A
NECESSARY COMPONENT OF THE
PROPOSAL. WELL THAT'S A GOOD TEE
UP FOR WHAT MY LAST QUESTION
WAS, AND THAT IS THE SINCE THE
PANDEMIC, THE ATTENDANTS
RECOVERY HAS BEEN FAIRLY
STUBBORN. IT IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ABLE TO BE DENTED IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY. AND SO MY SORT
OF QUESTION IS HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS SORT OF
GOING TO ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
THAT ARE THE THAT ARE CAUSING
ATTENDANCE NOT TO RECOVER THAT
ARE SORT OF THE REASON WHY WE'RE
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION. HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT IF WE WERE TO ADOPT
THIS, IT'S GONNA MOVE THE NEEDLE
WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE NOT MANY
THINGS HAVE MOVED THE NEEDLE IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
PERSON KEEPS NODDING, SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANNA GO UNLESS
YOU'RE FALLING ASLEEP. UH UH UH,
IF WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST BETWEEN
YOU AND FINANCE? JUST FOLLOWING
ALONG WITH OK, UH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HOW DO
YOU BELIEVE THIS IS ADDRESSING
THE LONG TERM ROOT CAUSES THAT
BRING US TO NEED SOMETHING FOR
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY, SIR II. I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT I COULD,
YOU KNOW, SPEAK, UH, VERY
CONCLUSIVELY TO THE BROADER ROOT
CAUSES OF CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM.
UM I THINK AS FAR AS THIS
PROPOSAL GOES, UM, YOU KNOW
AGAIN, WE JUST WANNA, YOU KNOW,
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL OPTION.
UM, THAT WOULD PROVIDE THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL AGE. LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. UM SO WITH
THE 15 MINUTE REQUIREMENT, UM
YOU KNOW, AS FAR AS YOU KNOW, I
THINK FOR SATURDAY SCHOOLS AND
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY OPTION, UM
RIGHT IS REQUIRED TO MEET, YOU
KNOW, MINIMUM DAY. UH,
REQUIREMENTS. UM YOU KNOW, IN
ORDER TO GENERATE A Dð A, UM SO
I THINK YOU KNOW THIS. THIS
WOULD PROVIDE, YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL TIMES BEFORE AFTER
SCHOOL. UM RIGHT. INTER
SESSIONAL PERIODS WEEKENDS. UM,
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, WOULD NOT
REQUIRE, UM THE LE A TO MEET
THOSE MINIMUM. THEY REQUIREMENTS
ALL AT THE SAME TIME, UM SO SORT
OF AS A WAY TO IMPROVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO, UH, ADDRESS THE
YOU KNOW, ATTENDANCE RECOVERY
CHRONIC A. LET ME ASK THE LEGIS.
ANALYSTS DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON HOW THIS DOES OR
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
THAT BRING THIS TO US? I THINK
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS IT. SORT OF THIS IS
SAYING THESE ABSENCES EXIST HERE
IS JUST A DIFFERENT WAY TO
GENERATE A Dð A FOR IT. NOW
WE'RE SETTING SOME CONDITIONS
THAT WE WANT THIS TO MEET SOME
REQUIREMENTS, SO IT IT CREATES,
UM SO THAT IT'S HELPING STUDENTS
LEARN, RIGHT. I. I THINK THE WE
DO HAVE WE HAVE SEEN FIRST JUST
GOING BACK TO ATTENDANCE ITSELF.
WE HAVE SEEN AN IMPROVEMENT IN
TERMS OF THE COMPARING
ATTENDANCE TO ENROLLMENT SINCE
THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN, UM UH
WE ARE NOT ANYWHERE NEAR WHERE
WE WERE. DURING THAT PANDEMIC
YEAR, WE HAD SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
ATTENDANCE RATES THAN WE DO NOW.
WE'RE STILL NOT BACK TO PRE
PANDEMIC, SO THAT IS STILL STILL
AN ISSUE. BUT I THINK THAT IS
PART OF THE, UM THE TOWN AND
PART OF WHY WE RAISED THE POINTS
REGARDING WHAT DO YOU WANT? WHAT
IS? WHAT DO YOU WANT THIS
PROGRAM AS A STATE? WHAT DO YOU
WANT THIS PROGRAM TO DO? UM,
RIGHT NOW IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE.
AND WE WOULD SAY, IF YOU'RE
GONNA CREATE THIS FLEXIBILITY,
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
LEADING TO STUDENT LEARNING AND
STUDENT PROGRESS RIGHT NOW, AND
I THINK ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS
LIKE WHAT IS THE POINT OF THIS
PROGRAM? AND HOW DO WE WANNA USE
IT? AND SO THAT'S WHY WE TALKED
ABOUT OUR OUR, UH, MY COLLEAGUE
MR TALKED ABOUT, UH, YOU KNOW,
FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT IS THIS
PROGRAM LIKE FOR HIGH SCHOOL?
INTERCESSION VERSUS DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR. IF WHAT'S GOING ON
IN STUDENTS ARE ABSENT, AND THEN
THEY'RE BEHIND AND THEY'RE
FAILING COURSES. WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO. GIVING GIVING
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY IN THE
SUMMER IS JUST LETTING THEM
FAIL, AND THEN AFTERWARDS,
PUTTING HIM IN THE SUMMER
PROGRAM TO MAKE UP THE COURSE.
MAYBE WE WOULD WANT TO PREFER
THAT THAT THAT IS MORE OF A THAT
WHAT YOU WANNA DO DURING THE
YEAR IS TO HELP SUPPORT THOSE
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY CAN GET
BETTER GRADES DURING THE YEAR,
RIGHT THAT THAT IT THAT SEEMED
LIKE THAT WOULD BE IN THAT CASE
IN THE CASE OF HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT'S A MORE HELPFUL THING. AND
MAYBE AN ELEMENTARY MIDDLE IS
NOT AS AS, UH, AS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT, BUT I THINK TRYING TO
GET IT TO WHAT IS IT THAT WE
WANT? THIS PROVIDES SO MUCH
FLEXIBILITY THAT, UM THAT THAT I
THINK THOSE KINDS OF QUESTIONS
ARE ANSWERED, AND WE REALLY JUST
LEAVE THEM TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO DECIDE HOW THEY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT THEM. BEFORE I MAKE A
COMMENT OVERALL, LET ME ASK IF
SENATOR WILK HAS A QUESTION OR A
COMMENT. I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION. I DO HAVE A COMMENT.
ONE. THERE'S NÓ DATA, SO I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE'RE GONNA AND IT'S
OPEN ENDED, SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU EVEN QUANTIFY THAT AND AGAIN
. THERE'S NOT GONNA BE ANY MONEY
AND I'D HATE TO SEE UH ANY CUTS
TO THE EXTENDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. I WOULD
REALLY LOVE TO SAY, UH, SAY EL
Ó P, BUT I'M NOT GONNA, UM SO,
SO THAT'S ONE BUT TWO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO ALL THOSE THINGS
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH ABSENTEEISM
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS IT'S.
IT'S SOCIETAL CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK IS REALLY UNFAIR TO DUMP
ON SCHOOLS, UH, TO HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT,
BECAUSE OF THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
FAMILY. UNFORTUNATELY WE MIGHT
HAVE TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION. I
WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO. BUT ALL
THESE THINGS ARE WORTHWHILE. I'M
NOT SURE IT'S GOING TO BE
ENOUGH. FRUSTRATING. UH UH.
WELL, WELL, THANK YOU. AND YOU
ACTUALLY TEED UP MY CLOSING
COMMENTS. FAIRLY WELL BECAUSE I
THINK BASED ON THIS DISCUSSION
THAT THAT I WILL JUST BE
CHARITABLE, AND SO I DON'T THINK
THIS PROPOSAL IS FULLY COOKED,
AND, UM AND IT IT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE TIED TO WHAT IT'S
RESOLVING, AND IN A WAY THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO MEASURE IT. IT
WOULD BE NICE IF WE HAD A SENSE
OF HOW MUCH IT COST AND WHETHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN DO THIS AT
A TIME THAT THE PROPOSAL NOW WAS
FOR A FRACTION OF ONE. PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA, AND YOU AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES OF
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN SMART TO IDENTIFY THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE AN ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY PROBLEM. IT'S JUST LIKE
HOW DO WE ARE WE SERIOUSLY GOING
TO ADDRESS THIS TO GET AT IT?
AND IT? ABOUT MOVING TO AN
ENROLLMENT SYSTEM FROM AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE AND UNDER
PROPOSITION 98. THE LITTLE
DISCUSSED THINGS. IT DOESN'T
REALLY WORK THERE. YEAH THERE'S
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD LOSE
AN AGGREGATE OF $5 BILLION,
SINCE SOME WOULD GAIN $5 BILLION
, AND UNLESS WE HAD MONEY TO
HOLD HARMLESS TO LOSERS, WE
WOULD JUST BE SHIFTING MONEY AND
CREATING BIGGER PROBLEMS AND ONE
OF THE ARGUMENTS FOR KEEPING THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE SYSTEM,
WHICH MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DON'T PARTICULARLY CARE FOR. IS
THAT IT PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO
MAKE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TRIED
TO GET KIDS IN CLASS. AND RIGHT
NOW THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND INCENTIVES THAT'S
IN THE WHOLE TOOLBOXES IS IF
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY CAN GET
KIDS INTO THE CLASSROOM, THEY
WILL GET PAID. IT'S A FINANCIAL
INSISTS INCENTIVE THAT WOULDN'T
EXIST WITH WITH AN ENROLLMENT
SYSTEM. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT AND JUST THE SUMMARY
WOULD BE. WE REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS THIS. WE WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
DEALING WITH TRYING TO GET BACK
TO PRE PANDEMIC IN ATTENDANCE.
I'M JUST NOT SURE THIS IS
TOGETHER ENOUGH TO WITH ANY
CONFIDENCE TO SAY THAT'S WHAT
WOULD BE HAPPENING IF WE ADOPTED
THIS PROPOSAL, SO I HOPE THAT
AND THE ADMINISTRATION REDUCED
THE TIME BETWEEN NOW AND MAY
15TH TO ADDRESS THOSE QUESTIONS
THAT IF THIS STAYS IN THE BUDGET
THAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE COSTS. WE
KNOW WHAT WOULD ACTUALLY UH, BE
AN OUTCOME. WE'D KNOW HOW WE
COULD MEASURE AN OUTCOME THAT
THAT WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
THING. SO I APPRECIATE AH, THE
DISCUSSION AND WE'LL SEE IF
PEOPLE WANT TO COME IN AT POINT
WHEN WE GET TO PUBLIC COMMENTS,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE IT AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
WHICH IS IN STRUCTURAL
CONTINUITY. AND WE HAVE K¾T
LAGOMARSINO FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. WE HAVE ELIZABETH
TEAR STAINED, SITTING IN ONCE
AGAIN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WE STILL HAVE MICHAEL
AFFAIRS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. UH, WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE AND WE WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER, SO WE'LL START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US. UM MY
NAME IS KATIE LAGOMARSINO WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
I'LL BE SPEAKING TO THE
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PIECE
OF OUR PROPOSAL. ONE OF THE
PRINCIPAL GOALS HERE IS TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS DON'T MISS
OUT ON CRITICAL INSTRUCTION AND
LEARNING WHILE THEY'RE ABSENT
FROM SCHOOL. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTION. STUDENTS WHO MISS
EVEN ONE DAY OF SCHOOL CAN FALL
BEHIND ON LEARNING AND FOR
STUDENTS WHO MAY BE FURTHER
BEHIND THEIR PEERS. THIS IMPACTS
THEIR CHANCES OF SUCCESS IN
SCHOOL AND BEYOND. OUR
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
PROPOSAL DOES A FEW THINGS
FIRST. IT STREAMS STREAMLINES
THE PROCESS FOR L E. A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING INSTRUCTION TO
STUDENTS THAT ARE ABSENT FROM
CLASSROOM BASED INSTRUCTION
THROUGH AN INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PROGRAM.
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
PROVIDES LIMITED TERM OPTIONS
FOR STUDENTS TO GENERATE
ATTENDANCE CREDIT THROUGH
SYNCHRONOUS OR ASYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION AND THROUGH
COMPLETED COURSEWORK. TO RECOVER
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE OR A D,
A THROUGH AN INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PROGRAM. STUDENTS
MUST BE UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
A CERTIFICATED TEACHER, WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
ATTENDANCE ATTENDANCE GENERATING
RULES. AS COMPARED TO CURRENT
SHORT TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY
AGREEMENTS. THE INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY AGREEMENT WOULD BE
MORE LIMITED IN SCOPE. AND COULD
BE SIGNED AT ANY POINT
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR,
THOUGH THE LANGUAGE ENCOURAGES
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
SIGN THEM AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR, WHEN POSSIBLE.
IN TERMS OF DAY LIMITATIONS,
STUDENTS COULD GENERATE UP TO 15
DAYS OF ATTENDANCE THROUGH
PARTICIPATION IN AN
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PROGRAM
PER YEAR SO THAT MAXIMUM IS
EXTENDED FOR STUDENTS IN
EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES. WE
ALSO PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
EMERGENCY ATTENDANCE
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING PROCESS
FOR A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
, ALSO KNOWN AS THE J 13, A
APPLICATION HERE. WE MAKE
CHANGES TO QUALIFY AS AN ACRONYM
. BUT BELIEVE ME, IT'S UP TO SEE
YEAH. UM SORRY TO KNOCK YOU OFF
YOUR GAME. THEY'RE INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT DISRUPTIONS TO
STUDENT LEARNING ARE MINIMIZED
AND ELLIE. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE NOT OVERLY BURDENED
DURING AN EMERGENCY.
SPECIFICALLY, WE MAKE CLEAR THAT
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT REQUIRED
FOR INSTRUCTION DURING AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT
OCCASIONS THE SUBMISSION OF A J
13 A AND WE CHANGED THE
PROVISION THAT SAYS A PLAN HAS
TO BE IN PLACE FOR INDEPENDENT
STUDY OR ONLINE INSTRUCTION
WITHIN 10 DAYS, CHANGING THAT TO
REQUIRING INSTRUCTION BE
PROVIDED WITHIN FIVE DAYS. AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE QUALITY
OF INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE AT
LEAST EQUIVALENT TO
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED. FINALLY WE
PROVIDE 6,000,001 TIME
PROPOSITION 98 GENERAL FUND FOR
TWO COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO CONDUCT RESEARCH ON MODELS OF
INSTRUCTION AND STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS. OF THE
TOTAL, AT LEAST 4 MILLION WOULD
BE PROVIDED TO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO RESEARCH BEST
PRACTICES FOR USING HYBRID AND
REMOTE MODELS OF INSTRUCTION. AS
WELL AS TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PROGRAMS. THE
SELECTED COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WOULD NEED TO MAKE THE
RESOURCE RESOURCES AND RESEARCH
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC THROUGH
A WEBSITE THAT LINKS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
WEBSITE AND THROUGH WIDELY
AVAILABLE AND FREE TRAININGS AND
CONVENING FOR LOCAL EDUCATION,
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
TEACHERS. AND UP TO 2,000,002
MILLION WOULD BE PROVIDED TO A
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
RESEARCH LOCAL STUDENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE NUANCED
TO TRACKING OF STUDENT ABSENCE
DATA WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON
ABSENCES DUE TO EMERGENCIES. THE
SELECTED COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION MUST PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO NOTED
ENTITIES BY JANUARY. 1ST OF 2026
. THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. HMM.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M ELIZABETH DEAR STEIN,
DIRECTOR FOR THE SCHOOL OF
FISCAL SERVICES DIVISION ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. TONY
THURMAN CD APPRECIATES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO CHALLENGES LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AGENCIES
HAVE FACED COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND THE IMPACT LOW
ATTENDANCE RATES HAVE HAD ON
LEARNING LESS AND FUNDING. WELL
THIS PROPOSAL ADDS ANOTHER
PROGRAM THAT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES CAN UTILIZE TO CLAIM
ATTENDANCE FOR APPORTIONMENT. IT
ALSO ADDS ANOTHER LAYER OF
COMPLEXITY AND THEN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ALREADY STRUGGLED TO UNDERSTAND
AND ADHERE TO THE CURRENT
ATTENDANCE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. IN ADDITION,
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
SIMILARITY TO THE CURRENT
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM HAS TO
POTENTIAL TO CREATE MORE
CONFUSION FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THAT INTENDED AS I
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL,
WE SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE TIMING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
AND LIAISE AT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT IN
THE UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE ON THESE PROPOSALS
AS THEY MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. AND THIS
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
THANK YOU, MR MICHAEL FEATHERS
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, SO WE HAVE COMMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL THREE PIECES
OF THESE PROPOSALS. START WITH
THIS. THE INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY. OUR OVERALL COMMENTS
ON INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY IS
THAT THIS THIS ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY THAT THIS WOULD
PROVIDE, COMPARED TO FOUR TO
MEET CURRENT SHORT TERM
INDEPENDENT STUDY WITH COULD BE
POSSIBLY BENEFICIAL FOR SCHOOLS
AND FOR STUDENTS, THOUGH, IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
ADOPTING THE PROPOSAL, WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LENGTHY
IMPLEMENTATION FOR AT LEAST A
YEAR AT THE PROPOSAL WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP RULES AND REGULATIONS
AROUND INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
PROGRAMS. AND LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
GENERATE FUNDING FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY UNTIL
THEY ADOPT POLICIES THAT ARE IN
LINE WITH THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT ARE SET FORTH
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION. UM THIS PROCESS WILL
LET YOU TAKE THEM SENT TO TAKE
SOME TIME TO SEE THROUGH AND
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO OFFER SHORT TERM
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAMS TO
STUDENTS. IN THE MEANTIME, AS
THE TRAILER BUILDING LANGUAGE
REMOVES ALL EXCEPTIONS FOR SHORT
TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY. DELETED
IMPLEMENTATION IS PROPOSAL FOR
AT LEAST A YEAR WOULD GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT TIME TO DEVELOP RULES
REGULATIONS AND FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO ADOPT THE
POLICIES AND COMPLIANCE. IN THE
CASE LEGISLATURES INTERESTED IN
ADOPTING THIS PROPOSAL. WE ALSO
RAISE SOME SPECIFIC ISSUES FOR
CONSIDERATION PRIOR TO ADOPTING.
THE FIRST ISSUE IS THAT ALTHOUGH
STRUCTURAL CONTINUITY WOULD BE
INTENDED TO BE USED FOR SHORT
PERIODS OF TIME, THE LANGUAGE
PROVIDES A BROAD EXCEPTION FOR
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE FOR
LONGER THAN 15 DAYS. IF THEY ARE
RAISING SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
PERSONAL DIFFICULTIES THAT MAKE
THEM UNABLE TO ATTEND SCHOOL.
THERE IS NO LIMIT ON HOW LONG
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY CAN BE
USED IN THESE CASES. UM
ADDITIONALLY, SINCE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR WHEN WRITTEN
AGREEMENTS MUST BE SIGNED IS ANY
TIME UNTIL THE END OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR. STUDENTS CAN BE ENROLLED
IN THESE PROGRAMS FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT HAVING
UNDERSTOOD EXPECTATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM. AND WITHOUT HAVING
KNOWN KEY DETAILS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE WRITTEN
AGREEMENTS. WE ALSO FOR ONE,
THESE ISSUES WE RECOMMEND
SETTING NARROWER EXCEPTIONS TO
THE 15TH DAY CAP. THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO SET
MORE SPECIFIC RULES FOR STUDENTS
WHO REMAIN ENROLLED BEYOND THE
15 DAY CAP, FOR EXAMPLE, SETTING
A MAXIMUM CAP FOR ALL STUDENTS
OR REQUIRING THAT IT WRITTEN
AGREEMENT MUST BE SIGNED BY THE
STUDENT AND PARENT OR GUARDIAN
PRIOR TO ENROLLING IN AN
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PROGRAM
THAT'S EXPECTED TO LAST MORE
THAN 15 DAYS. THIS WOULD ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS WITH LONGER TERM
NEEDS ARE ENROLLED IN THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAMS WHERE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT THEORY.
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES, THE
BETTER SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT COMPLETING THEIR COURSE
WORK. MOVING ON TO THE EMERGENCY
OF FUNDING PROPOSAL. WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHERE THEY'RE REQUIRING
ELI'S OR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO OFFER INSTRUCTION TO
ALL STUDENTS WITHIN FIVE
CALENDAR DAYS OF AN EMERGENCY
RATHER THAN 10 DAYS, AS
CURRENTLY UM, IT'S FEASIBLE
UNDER EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES,
PROVIDING INSTRUCTION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE COULD MITIGATE POSSIBLE
LEARNING LOSS AND COULD BENEFIT
STUDENTS ASSOCIATING EMOTIONALLY
BY GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INTERACT WITH FAMILIAR PEERS
AND ADULTS IN TERMS OF TIMES OF
POSSIBLE DISTRESS BUT IN CASES
OF MAJOR EMERGENCIES, OFFERING
INSTRUCTION WITHIN FIVE COUNTER
DUDE, THEY MAY BE PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING. ON THE LAST PIECE
ON THE ONE TIME GRANTS FOR DOING
FOR COUNTY OFFICERS TO DO
RESEARCH. WE JUST RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS FUNDING AS DUE TO
THE CURRENT BUDGET CONDITION AND
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN FUTURE YEARS AS
FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE, AND
SO THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS,
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UH LET ME JUST FIRST ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF YOU
WOULD RESPOND TO THE THREE
CONCERNS THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
JUST OUT POINT LIKE WHAT'S YOUR
VIEW ON THOSE?
IT SHOULD WORK, BUT LET'S SEE.
IF YOU STARTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, CAN I
SUMMARIZE THE THREE AS I THINK I
HEARD THEM. WELL, I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE MISSED THE FIRST ONE.
BUT I THINK THE SECOND ONE WAS
AROUND THE BROAD EXCEPTIONS FOR
PERSONAL DIFFICULTIES FOR
STUDENT GENERATING OVER THAT 15
DAY CAP. IS THAT RIGHT? IS THAT
THE FIRST ISSUE? TIMING OF THE
WRITTEN AGREEMENTS. OKAY,
ANYTIME WITH THE SCHOOL YEAR SO
STUDENTS COULD BE ENROLLED IN
THESE PROGRAMS WITHOUT HAVING
SIGNED THE AGREEMENT. I WANT TO
BE SURE TO ADDRESS ALL OF THIS.
UM GOOD MORNING. SO ON THE ON
THE BROAD EXCEPTIONS FOR
PERSONAL DIFFICULTIES WE DO
PROVIDE IN THE IN THE LANGUAGES
PROPOSED SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT
THOSE ARE SUCH AS, LIKE
HOMELESSNESS, HOUSING
INSTABILITY. WE ALLOW THE
PERSONAL DIFFICULTIES TO BE
BROAD ENOUGH TO CAPTURE OF WIDE
VARIETY OF SCENARIOS. AND SO UM,
WE DON'T ENUMERATE EVERY SINGLE
POSSIBLE POSSIBLE CAUSE OF HAVE
AN EXCEPTION. WE DO REQUIRE THAT
IT BE TRACKED, MONITORED
CLOSELY. BY THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND, UM IT
WOULD BE TO THE DISCUSSION OF
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT IS A
PERSONAL DIFFICULTY THAT
JUSTIFIES THAT EXTENDED OVER 15
DAY CAP. AND JUST ON THAT NOTE,
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE ELIA'S, UH,
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
THIS STUDENT HAS A NEED TO BE
ENROLLED IN REMOTE INSTRUCTION
OR INDEPENDENT STUDY. THE
INDEPENDENT, TRADITIONAL
INDEPENDENT STUDY WOULD BE
PROGRAM WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM, THEN THIS
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY
PROGRAM. THIS IS REALLY GEARED
FOR MORE SHORT TERM ABSENCES. UM
AND ON THE ON THE SECOND PIECE.
I'M GOING OUT OF ORDER.
SOMETHING APOLOGIZE. AND
ALTHOUGH LET ME JUST DO A QUICK
CLARIFICATION. WHEN YOU SAY
SHORT TERM ABSENCES, YOU'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT NATURAL DISASTER,
SHORT TERM MASTER ABSENCES,
WHICH I REALLY THOUGHT WAS A
PART OF THIS. THIS. THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE. SO YES, THAT COULD BE
A SHORT TERM. UH CAUSE FOR SHORT
TERM ABSENCE. OKAY. KEEP GOING.
UM ON WHETHER EMERGENCY FUNDING
FOR FIVE DAYS PROVIDING
EDUCATION WITHIN FIVE DAYS OR
OFFERING INSTRUCTION, SO THE WAY
THEIR LANGUAGES PROPOSED NOW IS
BEGINNING IN JULY 1ST OF THIS
YEAR THE PROPOSAL WOULD CHANGE
THAT 10 DAYS TO FIVE DAYS. THEY
BELIEVE ON PAGE 12 OF OUR AGENDA
. UH THE ELIO ACTUALLY HAS A
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE CHART OF SUMMER
OF LIKE THE KINDS OF, UM HOW
MANY ELIA'S ARE ACTUALLY FILED A
30 NASER THE EMERGENCY FUNDING
APPLICATION THAT LAST FOR MORE
THAN FIVE DAYS, AND IT'S ONLY
LIKE 17.5% SO THE VAST MAJORITY
ARE UNDER THAT FIVE DAY
THRESHOLD. UM SO WE THINK MOSTLY
A'S WOULD NOT, YOU KNOW, BE
HINDERED BY THIS REQUIREMENT
OFFER INSTRUCTION. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT. ACTUALLY OFFERING
INSTRUCTION. MOST ALIENS HAVE
FILED 13 AND I BELIEVE THAT ARE
APPROVED TO HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN.
FOR OFFERING INSTRUCTION, BUT NO
ACTUAL, UM, REQUIREMENT TO OFFER
THAT INSTRUCTION AND SO, UM, ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD DO BEGINNING JULY 1ST
2025, IS IT? EXCUSE ME. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT OFFERING TO
ACTUALLY OCCUR SO UM, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT CAN BE SEEN AS
BURDENSOME. BUT WE IN OUR
PROPOSAL, UM, REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF INDEPENDENT
STUDIES. SO WE TRY TO MAKE IT AS
WE DON'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
THAT INSTRUCTION CAN LOOK LIKE
IT COULD BE REMOVED THE
REQUIREMENT OR REMOVE THE OPTION
. REMOVE THEIR WE REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF INDEPENDENT
STUDY FOR THAT EMERGENCY
INSTRUCTION. UM BEGINNING JULY
1ST 2025 WITHIN FIVE DAYS, THEY
HAVE TO OFFER INSTRUCTION. THEY
HAVE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
INSTRUCTION OR, UM, FACILITATE
THE ENROLLMENT OF THAT STUDENT
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS IN A
NEIGHBORING L E. A AND THAT CAN
ALSO BE ONLINE INSTRUCTION AT
THE NEIGHBORING ELIA OR ONLINE
INSTRUCTION. UM AS PROVIDED SO
IT CAN BE. IT'S A PRETTY
FLEXIBLE, UM, REQUIREMENT, UM,
IN TERMS OF AND 13 DAYS ARE
OPTIONAL APPLICATION MOST LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT FACE
AN EMERGENCY DO CHOOSE TO FILE
THEM SO THAT THEIR ATTENDANCE
CAN BE HELD HARMLESS AND THEN ON
THE TIMING OF THE WRITTEN
AGREEMENTS THAT THE NOTED AND
THAT IT CAN BE SIGNED AT ANY
POINT. ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
ISSUES WE'VE BEEN HEARING IS
THAT RATHER THAN UM, AND
PROVIDING ANY INSTRUCTION, THE
WRITTEN AGREEMENT IS SEEN AS A
KIND OF LIKE A BURDEN, EVEN WITH
A SHORT TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY
GUIDELINES. I THINK IT'S OFFERED
THAT WRITTEN AGREEMENT HAS TO BE
ASSIGNED WITHIN 10 DAYS. WE'VE
REMOVED THAT TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING THAT
INSTRUCTION AND TRYING TO REMOVE
ANOTHER AN ADDITIONAL BARRIER.
AND SO WE THINK WE THINK MOST
ELIA'S WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT INSTRUCTION WITHIN FIVE
DAYS. WE THINK REMOVING KIND OF
THE WHAT OUR SENIORS, OWNERS AND
REQUIREMENTS OF INDEPENDENT
STUDY THOSE ARE REMOVED. SO UM,
REALLY PROVIDING A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITIES TO ENSURE THE
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING THAT
CONTENT, CONTINUITY OF LEARNING.
THEN A LET ME MAKE A COMMENT. UH
A COUPLE OF VOICE FIRST. UM YOU
I SPEAK EVERY YEAR AT THE
REGIONAL CONFERENCE OF THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN MY
DISTRICT, AND THEY WERE, UM
WORKED UP ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
LET'S JUST SAY THAT AND FLEXIBLE
IS NOT A WORD I HEARD IN THEIR
DESCRIPTION ABOUT IT. IT'S SO,
UH, IT SOUNDED TO ME LIKE HMM.
IT WAS THEIR VIEW. THIS WAS
GOING TO BE VERY HARD AND PUT A
LOT OF ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AND I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY AND YOU DO IT AND THEN
AS HAVING A DISTRICT THAT'S
DISASTER PRONE. UM YOU KNOW THE
SLIDE ON HIGHWAY ONE THAT IS
CLOSED IT FOR 14 MONTHS, AND ONE
AREA HAS SPLIT A SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE MIDDLE. AH AND UNLESS
THEY DRIVE FOUR HOURS, AND NOW
WITH THE SLIP OUT OF THE NORTH,
THEY CAN'T EVEN DRIVE FOUR HOURS
TO GET TO THE OTHER PART. IT
PRESENTS THESE THESE HURDLES.
AND I HAVE ANOTHER PLACE WHERE
27% OF THE STUDENTS WERE IN A
HOUSE THAT BURNED DOWN IN ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND YOU COULDN'T
ACCESS TO SCHOOL. AND YOU KNOW,
AND I ALSO REPRESENT POVERO
WHERE THE SCHOOL THAT WAS
FLOODED IN THE FLOOD WHEN THE
LEVEE BROKE LAST YEAR STILL HAS
NOT REOPENED AND IN THE NOTION
OF TAKING AN ENTIRE STUDENT BODY
HAD RELOCATING THEM SOMEWHERE
AND DOING IT IN A MATTER OF DAYS
WHEN YOU STILL CAN'T ACCESS A
LOT OF PLACES IN THE DISTRICT IS
REALLY HARD AND SENATOR WILK AND
I SIT ON THE STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD AND WE HAD AN ITEM IN
FRONT OF US YESTERDAY ABOUT A
ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND LASSEN
COUNTY, WHERE THE SCHOOL
COMPLETELY BURNED DOWN AND THE
NEAREST OPTION WAS 30 MINUTES
AWAY WITH THERE NOT BEING AH
TOTAL INTERNET ACCESS FOR THE
STUDENTS IN THAT DISTRICT. AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT WHILE THIS
IS WELL INTENTIONED BECAUSE THE
PRESENTATION INITIALLY SAID ALL
THE REASONS WHY WE NEED TO HAVE
CONTINUITY, NO DISAGREEMENT.
THAN THE PROPOSAL FOR HOW THE
CONTINUITY DOES SEEMS LIKE IT
STILL NEEDS A LOT OF WORK AND SO
FOR ME, AND I'LL ASK IF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY COMMENTS FOR
ME. POLICE WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND TRIED TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE I
THINK UH, THE SHORTNESS OF THIS
SOME OF THE OPTIONS AND I GET
THAT PANDEMIC OR CERTAIN ILLNESS
OR CERTAIN OTHER THINGS WOULD
PRESENT OR UNSHELTERED PEOPLE
WOULD PRESENT EVEN DIFFERENT
THINGS THAN THE DISASTERS. SO
JUST I WOULD ASK THAT YOU WORK
ON THIS BEFORE WE SEE IT AGAIN.
LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NO, I WAS I'M THE SAME
WAY WITH YOU. IN TERMS OF, YOU
KNOW, NATURAL DISASTERS OR
WHATEVER I'VE HAD NUMEROUS IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE FIVE DAYS SEEMED
REALLY UNREASONABLE. RIGHT?
AGAIN I THINK THEY NEED TO COME
BACK. BETTER PROPOSAL. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE UM THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR LAST ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR LEARNING
RECOVER RECOVERY EMERGENCY BLOCK
GRANTS AND WE HAVE YOU GO. SALAS
GALLIAN, A FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, WILLIAM MCGEE, FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND I ASSUME SINCE MR
CABRAL IS THERE, THAT'S WHO IS
GOING TO BE HERE FOR THE JUST SO
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HUGO SALAS COLONNA
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LV SPEAKING ABOUT THE LEARNING
RECOVERY, EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT
PROPOSAL THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES CHANGES THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEFS ARE
APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME. UM AT
THIS STAGE, COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC TO FOCUS THE USE OF AND
ITS SPENDING AT ONE TIME DOLLARS
ALLOCATED BY THE LEARNING
RECOVERY EMERGENCY BLOCK GRAND
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS OF
AVAILABILITY ON STUDENTS WHO
WERE MOST IMPACTED AND CONTINUE
TO NEED SUPPORT. PROPOSING THESE
CHANGES ALSO ALLOWED THE STATE
TO RESOLVE THAT KAYLA J.
LITIGATION. SPECIFICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
MADE UP OF A FEW DIFFERENT
PIECES FIRST ON THE LEARNING
RECOVERY, EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
RECEIVING THIS GROUND WILL HAVE
TO DEVELOP A NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
MEASURE WHICH STUDENTS ARE MOST
IN NEED OF LEARNING RECOVERY
SUPPORT AND TARGET THE USE AND
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS THAT ARE
UNENCUMBERED AS OF JULY 1ST 2024
ON ADDRESSING THOSE STUDENT
NEEDS AS PART OF THE ASSESSMENT
SCHOOL, TONY WILL HAVE TO REVIEW
METRICS FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE,
ARTS, MATH AND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM ACROSS SCHOOL SITES,
AND THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
STUDENT GROUPS AND THE VERY LOW
AND LOW STATUS ON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DASHBOARD AND FOR ALL
STUDENTS WORK CHRONICALLY
ABSENT. AS YOU'LL RECALL THE
BLOG, GRAHAM PROVIDED $6.8
BILLION TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES IN RESPONSE TO THE
EMERGENCY CAUSED BY THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. TO HELP SCHOOLS
SERVING STUDENTS. IN LONG TERM
RECOVERY FROM THE 22 TO 23
SQUARE TO THE 27TH 28 SCHOOL
YEAR, SECOND ON THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN.
THE U. THE USE OF BLOCK GRANT
FUNDS STAR UNENCUMBERED AS OF
JULY, 1ST 2024 WILL HAVE TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANTS FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS OF THE GRANT.
WITH THE RATIONALES AND
RESEARCHED, JUSTIFYING THE
ACTION SHOWING HOW THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING THE GREATEST NEED. UH SO
THE YEARS THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED
ARE THE 2025 2626 TO 27 AND 27
TO 28 SCHOOL YEARS OF THE
VARIOUS THINGS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED HERE. SCHOOLS WILL HAVE
TO IDENTIFY PLANNED TO SPEND THE
TRUCE USING BLOCK GRANT FUNDS
WITHIN THE DESCRIPTIONS OF
ASSOCIATED ACTIONS AND ANALYSIS
OF THE IMPLEMENTED. NATION OF
THOSE PLANS, EXPENDITURES. AND
THE LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANTS. ANNUAL UPDATE. THIRD ON
THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT, AND
THEY SHOULD HAVE COMPONENT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL LET EXCELLENT AND
THE LEAD AGENCY FOR THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE,
WHICH IS THE UH SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WOULD BE
ENCOURAGED TO INCORPORATE
LEARNING RECOVERY WORK AND TO
THE TRAINING AND RESOURCES THEY
PROVIDE TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. AND, UH, YES, AND
FINALLY ON THE UNIFORM COMPLAINT
PROCEDURE PROCESS. WE CLARIFY
THAT ANYONE CAN FILE A
COMPLAINT, INCLUDING A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC REGARDING THAT
MEETING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN. THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS,
AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WELCOME.
GREAT THANK YOU. AND GOOD
MORNING TO EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
WILLIAM MCGEE. AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND SUPPORT DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION GREETINGS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS AND
COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. I WILL TALK ABOUT
THE PROGRAMMATIC AREAS OF THE
LEARNING RECOVERY EMERGENCY
BLACK GRANT AS FINANCES COVERED
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. AS
WAS MENTIONED. THE BLACK GRANT
WAS SENT OUT FOR 6,800,050,000,
AND IT WAS SENT OUT IN TWO EQUAL
PAYMENTS. SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVED
LEARNING RECOVERY. EMERGENCY
BLOCK GRANT FUNDS RELEASED IN
TWO EQUAL PAYMENTS OF 3
3,000,000,900. MILLION 68.
EXCUSE ME? $968 MILLION, THE
FIRST IN NOVEMBER OF 2022 AND
THE SECOND AND APRIL OF 2023.
THE APPORTIONMENT WERE PAID TO
THE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
THE FIRST INTERIM EXPENDITURE
REPORTS ARE DUE DECEMBER 15TH
2024 TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND WILL
ALLOW FOR THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO DOCUMENT THEIR
EXPENDITURE DATA. THE INTERIM
EXPENDITURE REPORT WILL ENSURE
THAT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
DO NOT CLAIM EXPENDITURES
GREATER THAN THE AMOUNT OF THEIR
TOTAL BLACK GRANT ALLOCATION.
PROVIDE THE AMOUNT OF
EXPENDITURES DISAGGREGATED BY
ALLOWABLE USE TO ENSURE EVERY
DOLLAR WAS EXPENDED AND HAS DONE
SO WITHIN THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BLACK GRANT AND THAT ALL
DATA POINTS PROVIDED ARE
COMPLETE AND CALCULATED
ACCURATELY. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE ENCOURAGED TO
UTILIZE THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN TO
COMMUNICATE THEIR STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR HOW FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES. A
STATUTE DOES NOT REQUIRE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO DEVELOP
A PLAN. WE HAVE NOT YET
COLLECTED EXAMPLES FROM ELIA'S
OR AT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
, AS THE FIRST REPORT IS DUE
DECEMBER 1520 24 WHILE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DOES NOT APPROVE OR
DENY FUNDS OR REQUESTS REGARDING
PROPOSED EXPENDITURES. THE
FOLLOWING ARE EXAMPLES OF
INQUIRIES THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
POSSIBLE USE OF FUNDS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND THEIR COMMUNITY.
CURRICULUM EMBEDDED WITH LINGUAL
ENGLISH LANGUAGE SUPPORT. ACCESS
TO ONLINE DIGITAL PROGRAMS OF
SUBSCRIPTIONS, LITERACY RELATED
TRAININGS, COMPUTERS I T
INFRASTRUCTURE, HIGH SPEED
INTERNET FOR RURAL FAMILIES
TEACHER IT ATTENTION
INTERVENTION, TEACHERS
ASSESSMENT COORDINATOR.
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND COUNSELORS ARE
SOME OF THE INQUIRIES THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED. SO AGAIN, THE REPORT
WILL BE DECEMBER 1520 24 AND
WILL HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE SPENT
THEIR MONEY AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I'LL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
EDGAR COBRA WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE JUST HAVE,
UM, COMMENT RELATED TO ONE
SPECIFIC PART OF THIS, WHICH IS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
CLARIFY THAT THE LEARNING
RECOVERY EMERGENCY BLOCK CRAFT
FUNDS CAN BE USED. MATHEMATICS
FRAMEWORK, PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THING THAT
PROPOSAL. WE THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH OVERALL BROADER
GOAL OF THE BLACK GROUND ITSELF.
AH! LET ME ASK. MY ONLY QUESTION
WAS GOING TO BE ABOUT THAT. SO
LET ME ASK ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE
THE ONE THING WAS IS THAT WAS
NOT A STIPULATION OF THE
SETTLEMENT. AND SO IS IT
BASICALLY. YEAH GETTING YOU TO
SPEAK FOR EVERYBODY IN FINANCE.
WAS IT BASICALLY THE VIEW OF THE
FINANCE? THAT'S A GOOD THING TO
DO, AND IT HELPS THIS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT REQUIRED BY THE,
UH THE SETTLEMENT. HE WAS SALAS
GALENA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE MATH FRAMEWORK.
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ALIGNS
WITH ONE OF THE BLOCK GRANT
SCHOOLS OF LEARNING RECOVERY IN
KEY AREAS SUCH AS MATH, AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS NECESSARY TO THEORY
TO MAINTAIN THAT PROGRESS EVEN
IF IT ISN'T A STIPULATION OF
EVEN IF IT ISN'T A STIPULATION
OF THE SETTLEMENT, UH, THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WOULD
INCLUDE ACTIONS. THAT WOULD HELP
SCHOOLS CLOSE LEARNING GAPS IN
MATH, INCLUDING ACTIONS LIKE
TRAINING TEACHERS, HIRING MATH
COACHES AND CONTRACTING
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD RELEVANT
INSTRUCTIONAL TOOLS. OKAY? THEN
LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SIGN.
I'M A BIT OF A MACRO SENATOR.
MEN HAVE A BIT OF A MACRO
QUESTION SLASH COMMENT, AND I
GUESS IT REVOLVES AROUND THIS
IDEA. JUST STEPPING BACK. WE'RE
NOW TWO YEARS INTO BACK INTO IN
PERSON LEARNING, AND, UM, AS WE
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD, I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF THE L E A S THAT I
COMMUNICATE WITH THE CONCERNS
ARE SHIFTING MORE AWAY FROM
LEARNING LOSS RECOVERY INTO JUST
GENERAL TEACHER ATTENTION. A LOT
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AROUND THE STATE AND I
GUESS I'M WONDERING IF
CONSIDERATION IS BEING GIVEN TO
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IF WE
CONTINUE TO FACE BUDGET PRESSURE
PROVIDING MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PART OF FUNDING
TO BE REDEPLOYED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. AND THAT COULD BE A
QUESTION FOR YOU KNOW, UH,
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS WELL.
LENA GRANT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING IF WE CAN RE APPROPRIATE
THE FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO THE LEARNING
RECOVERY BLOCK GRANT EVERYBODY
BLOCKING IT TO OTHER PURPOSES. I
GUESS THAT WOULD FALL ON US
SECTION. THAT'S MY MISTAKE. BUT
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE
DISCUSSED? I GUESS IS THE
BROADER QUESTION BECAUSE I KNOW
WE COMMITTED THESE FUNDS. BUT WE
IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW ARE ARE
DEALING WITH. YOU KNOW, WE WERE
COMING OUT. WE'RE ALL TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO FREEZE,
DELAY AND ROLLBACK FUNDING. AND
SO IS THIS SOMETHING WHERE YOU
HAVE AN OPINION ON POTENTIAL THE
POTENTIAL SHIFTING OF THIS
TOWARDS OTHER PRIORITIES.
POTENTIAL? SURE, UM UH, WE HAVE
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION SEE
THAT THIS LEARNING RECOVERY
EMERGENCY BLOCK GRANT AS A WHILE
YOU SAID THAT MOST SCHOOLS ARE
NOT REALLY CONCERNED WITH THE
LEARNING LOSS, POTENTIALLY
POTENTIALLY WITH THE FOLLOWING
COVID 19, WE DO SEE THAT STUDENT
STUDENTS PERFORMANCE ON
ASSESSMENT ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE
PROVIDED THAT THEY'RE STILL
LAGGING BEHIND COVID 1920 20
LEVELS AND WE SO WE SEE THAT AS
A CONTINUED PRIORITY. WE HAVE
NOT CONSIDERED SHIFTING THESE
FUNDS IN PARTICULAR TO ANY OTHER
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY ANY OTHER
ANY SHIFTS THIS AS CURRENTLY, UM
PROPOSED THIS LANGUAGE IS PART
OF THIS. THE LANGUAGE CHANGES
BEFORE YOU ARE PART OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AND SO ANY
CHANGES TO THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO, UM NEGOTIATING RIGHT? OKAY
JUST TO BE CLEAR. I WAS NOT
SAYING THAT LEARNING LAST NIGHT
AN ISSUE. I'M SAYING THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF ISSUES WITH OUR
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW AND AS WE'RE
MOVING FURTHER AND FURTHER IN
TIME AWAY FROM THE POINT IN
TIME, WHEN STUDENTS WERE
LEARNING REMOTELY AND ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT THAT PROVIDED,
UH, YOU KNOW, I HEAR FROM MY
ELIA'S THAT THERE ARE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT FOR SOME OF THEM,
UH, BEGIN TO ECLIPSE LEARNING
LOTS RECOVERY, BUT THANKS.
THOUGHTS ARE IN YES. SO I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE TALKED
WITH SOME OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ASK THEM WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN USING THE FUNDS FOR
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN FOR
LIKE TEACHERS ON SPECIAL
ASSIGNMENT CERTIFICATED STAFF TO
HELP REDUCE CLASS SIZES. SO I
THINK IF I UNDERSTOOD YOUR
QUESTION CORRECTLY, THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE UTILIZING THE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THOSE GOALS
THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING ALONG
WITH ALSO WHAT LINA MENTIONED AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER.
THEN, UH, LET ME JUST MAKE SORT
OF A CLOSING COMMENT HERE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION, AND I
THINK IT IS ALWAYS HARD FOR US.
TO IMPLEMENT A SETTLEMENT THAT
WE WEREN'T A PARTY TO AND
WEREN'T REALLY CONSULTED ABOUT,
PRESUMES WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
ON THE BUDGET THAT THAT IS JUST
ALWAYS VERY DIFFICULT. AND
FORTUNATELY, THIS ONE IS NOT FAR
OFF FROM WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN ANYWAY. BUT JUST FOR THE
RECORD, IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO GET
A PHONE CALL. WHEN YOU'RE DOING
THIS SAID YOU REALLY WANT TO
APPROPRIATE A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS RATHER THAN THEY'RE
JUST BEING A PRESUMPTION THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO, UM I APPRECIATE, UH, THIS
DISCUSSION AND AS OPPOSED TO THE
OTHER ITEMS. I'M NOT SURE
THERE'S AS MUCH WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE ON THIS, AS WE HAD TO
THE MAY REVISE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS ON THIS FROM MEMBERS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. THEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. THAT COMPLETES OUR
CONSIDERATION OF THE FOUR ITEMS
THAT WE HAD IN FRONT OF US, BUT
WE DO STILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT,
SO LET ME ASK FOR A SHOW OF
HANDS OF WHO WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN PUBLIC COMMENT. 12345
IS WHAT I SEE SO THEN WILL ALLOW
FOR UP TO TWO MINUTES, UH, FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND POLICE. MOVED
TO THE MICROPHONE AND WE WILL
HAVE COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE FOUR
ISSUES FOR, UH UP TO TWO
MINUTES. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING, GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DERRICK LENNOX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SUPER
INTENSIVE WHEN I SPEAK TO TWO
ISSUES. THE FIRST IS ON
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY AND
ATTENDANTS RECOVERY WANT TO GIVE
APPRECIATION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT IN
ADDRESSING CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
THROUGH MORE STREAMLINED
EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS. I THINK ALL
OF US ARE IN FAVOR OF THAT, BUT
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE CHAIR
AND THE LOWS, ASSESSMENTS ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
ELIA'S MIGHT FACE AND ADOPTING
THOSE WE'VE HAD A QUICK
SUCCESSION OF REMOTE AND VIRTUAL
LEARNING OPTIONS OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS, ALL OF THEM
ASSOCIATED WITH DIFFERENT AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS AND PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE THINK A
LITTLE BIT MORE STUDY WOULD BE
QUITE VALUABLE ON THAT ISSUE.
FOR THE SECOND ISSUE AROUND THE
EMERGENCY RECOVERY. I'LL BE
SPEAKING ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AS WELL AS THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS, AND THAT IS TO
SAY THAT FOR EMERGENCIES LASTING
FIVE OR MORE DAYS, THE PROPOSED
INSTRUCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS ARE
OFTEN INFEASIBLE AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED HERE, AND I HEARD YOU
ALL TALK ABOUT AND THAT HAS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS IN
SCHOOLS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. UM
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT DURING THESE
EMERGENCIES SCHOOLS OFTEN PIVOT
PLAYING AN ESSENTIAL ROLE IN THE
COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF REACHING
OUT TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
DOING WELLNESS CHECKS, SERVING
AS HUBS FOR TEMPORARY HOUSING OR
FOR FEMA, AND A LOT OF THAT
CONTACT IS OCCURRING, BUT IT MAY
NOT BE AT THE STANDARDS THAT ARE
PROVIDED FOR IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND THAT'S DEEPLY
CONCERNING BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ALREADY QUITE SUFFERING OR
DISPLACED DURING THOSE
EMERGENCIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THIS DISCUSSION. MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SPEND NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN YOUTH.
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON ISSUES
ONE AND TWO ELOPE AND ATTENDANCE
RECOVERY AS YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR
OWN DISTRICTS AND HER TODAY
ELOPE PROVIDES ACCESS TO
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIPS AND
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
INCREASES ATTENDANCE AND
GRADUATION RATES FOR THOUSANDS
MORE STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND
ADDRESSING CHALLENGES TO
INCREASING LEARNING AND
RECOVERING ATTENDANCE FUNDING.
BUT WE AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE TODAY THAT THERE ARE WAYS
TO STRENGTHEN THE PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT
ATTENDS RECOVERY IS ALIGNED WITH
EXISTING EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS. WE SHOULDN'T OVER
BURDEN SCHOOLS WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE HURDLES, SUCH AS
CREATING AND STAFFING MULTIPLE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. INSTEAD LET'S
COORDINATE WITH EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND STAFFING SO THAT
ATTENDANTS RECOVERY CAN HAPPEN
MORE QUICKLY WITH LESS COST AND
REACH MORE STUDENTS. AND SECOND
TEACHERS SHOULD OVERSEE
INSTRUCTION, BUT WE URGE YOU TO
ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY. ALLOW
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO WORK WITH
TEACHERS TO PROVIDE ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT HELP KEEP
KIDS COMING AND ALLOW COMMUNITY
PARTNERS TO EMPLOY CERTIFICATED
TEACHERS TO HELP MEET STUDENTS
NEEDS. THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES CHANGING THE DEFINITION
OF EXPLAINED LEARNING. TO ALLOW
DISTRICTS TO USE THEM FOR
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY. BUT
EXPANDED LEARNING IS SO SPECIAL
BECAUSE IT COMPLEMENTS BUT
DOESN'T REPLICATE THE SCHOOL
DAY. CHANGING THE ONGOING
DEFINITION OF EXPANDED LEARNING
WILL NOT ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF WIVES. STUDENTS ARE
NOT ATTENDING SCHOOL. THIS
CHANGE COULD EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM BY DISCOURAGING SCHOOLS
FROM OFFERING NON TRADITIONAL
EXPERIENCES STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES NEED AND DESERVE.
FINALLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
OLDER YOUTH EXPERIENCE HIGHER
LEVELS OF ABSENTEEISM, THEN
ELEMENTARY STUDENTS, BUT YELLOW
IS PRIORITIZED FOR T K THROUGH
SIXTH GRADE STUDENTS. WE AGREE
WITH HELIOS EARLIER COMMENTS
THAT YELLOW CAN BE USED IN
CREATIVE WAYS TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES FACED BY STUDENTS AT
DIFFERENT GRADE LEVELS, FOR
EXAMPLE, EXPANDED LEARNING CAN
HELP HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS APPLY
FOR COLLEGE AND FINANCIAL AID.
PORT DUAL ENROLLMENT LINK
LEARNING INTERNSHIPS AND CREDIT
RECOVERY. AND TO YOUR EARLIER
POINT, SENATOR LAIRD, WE MUST
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF WHY
STUDENTS ARE COMING TO SCHOOL.
WE BELIEVE EXPANDED LEARNING IS
PART OF THAT SOLUTION BY
PROVIDING SPACES WHERE STUDENTS
WANT TO COME AND LEARN OUTSIDE
OF THE TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, SIERRA COOK
WITH THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'M HERE TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE. THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM. UM, JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WHILE THE HOLD
HARMLESS THAT'S IN PLACE DOES
PROTECT DISTRICTS THAT MIGHT
FLIP FROM RECEIVING RATE ONE TO
RECEIVING RATE TO IT DOES
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
INSTABILITY THAT IS BAKED INTO
THE FORMULA FOR RATE TO ITSELF
RIGHT TO IS DEPENDENT ON
STATEWIDE T K THROUGH 688, WHICH
MAKES IT INHERENTLY UNSTABLE,
BUT PARTICULARLY SO IN THESE
YEARS OF TK EXPANSION AS
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS OR IN
THE AGENDA. UM LAST YEAR, RIGHT
TO DISTRICTS EXPERIENCED $250
PER STUDENT DROP IN THEIR
ALLOCATION. THAT WAS A 12% CUT
THAT WAS RECEIVED ONLY EIGHT
WEEKS BEFORE THE START OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR. AND AS TK EXPANSION
CONTINUES, WE ASSUME THAT THIS
TREND WILL CONTINUE AS WELL.
THIS PUTS DISTRICTS WHO RECEIVE
RIGHT TO IN THE POSITION OF
HAVING TO PLAN THEIR PROGRAM
OFFERINGS MAKE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
PROVIDE THOSE OFFERINGS, HIRE
STAFF, UM AND PLAN THEIR ENTIRE
PROGRAM WITHOUT KNOWING HOW MUCH
MONEY THEY'LL RECEIVE. SO UM, WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION OF THE
IMPACT OF THOSE RATES
INSTABILITIES, BUT JUST WANTED
TO ELEVATE THAT UNLESS RATE TWO
IS STABILIZED IF IT CONTINUES TO
DECREASE DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE
THIS RATE WILL REALLY STRUGGLE
TO MEET THE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
AND PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR, SOMETHING UP
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF MICHELLE GAYLE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS WILL
BE JUST SPEAKING REGARDING TWO
OF THE ISSUES FIRSTLY, ABOUT
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY IN
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY PROGRAMS. WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS
REGARDING READINESS, CLARITY AND
REGULATIONS AND TIMELY
INTEGRATION INTO THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT GUIDANCE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND ALIGNMENT WITH
THE AUDIT PROCESS, AND, UM,
SECONDLY, REGARDING THE CHANGES
TO THE EMERGENCY TENANTS,
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME FRAME. WE
OPPOSE THE PROPOSED FIVE DAYS.
TIMEFRAME FOR ILIAS TO CERTIFY
PLANS OF OFFERING INSTRUCTION
DURING EMERGENCIES DUE TO THE
RANGE OF EMERGENCIES. THAT MAY
ARISE AND POTENTIAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IMPLEMENTATIONS AS
WELL. AND DURING THIS EMERGENCY
IS NOT JUST THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE BEING AFFECTED. ALSO
TEACHERS ADMIN AND THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY SO WE WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK FOR 10
DAYTIME FROM THAT IS IN
EXISTENCE RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING, SENATOR LAIRD AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANA YOAKUM
BEADS ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
REGARDING ISSUE ONE, THE
EXTENDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM. WE ARE A TIER ONE
SCHOOL AND WE WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PROTECT OUR
EXTENDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM FUNDING AND ALSO TO
CONSIDER IN LIGHT OF THE
EXPIRATION OF THE FEDERAL SER.
I'M SORRY. I DO NOT CANNOT SAY
THE ACRONYM OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD IN LIGHT OF THE EXPIRATION
OF FEDERAL COVID 19 FUNDS AND
OTHER POTENTIAL BUDGET
REDUCTIONS AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY
AS POSSIBLE IN BOTH THE EXTENDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
AND OTHER GRANTS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO HELP US CREATIVELY
AND FLEXIBLY MOVE FUNDS AROUND
TO MAINTAIN SERVICES TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. IN REGARDS
TO ATTENDANCE, RECOVERY AND
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY, JUST
WANT TO ECHO AND UPLIFT THE
COMMENTS THAT OTHERS HAVE MADE.
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ATTENDANCE RECOVERY, BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT MORE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE HELPFUL.
UM, WE HAVE WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT FIVE DAYS NOT
BEING ENOUGH TIME IN A TRUE
EMERGENCY. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
15 MINUTE INCREMENTS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT, UH HMM. THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO CREATE MORE
FLEXIBILITY. OUR STAFF HAVE
SHARED THAT THEY ACTUALLY THINK
THAT WOULD CREATE FAR MORE
CHALLENGES AND THAT A ONE HOUR
TIMEFRAME WOULD BE PREFERABLE.
AND FINALLY, THAT STUDENTS WITH
AN I P BE ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE
WITH PARENTAL CONSENT. THE SAME
AS OTHER STUDENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS. MARGALIS EAGLE
WITH GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF
OF ASPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
PROVIDING SHORT COMMENTS ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ASPIRE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SERVES STUDENTS ACROSS
THREE DIFFERENT REGIONS BAY AREA
, CENTRAL VALLEY AND LOS ANGELES
SPIRE SUPPORTS THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
FUNDING AND IT'S ALLOWED THEM TO
ADD ADDITIONAL ONGOING ACADEMIC
AND ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ASPIRE SCHOLARS. THEY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO USE
THIS FUNDING MOVING FORWARD
TOWARDS THIS PURPOSE AND URGE
YOU TO PROTECT THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SEEING NO ONE ELSE, UH, IN
LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. LET ME
THANK EVERYBODY THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE HEARING
TODAY AND MADE COMMENTS. THAT
COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY,
LET ME JUST REPEAT WHAT I DID AT
THE OUTSET OF THE HEARING THAT
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR THROUGH THE
WEBSITE, YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT AND WE
WANT TO TAKE THEM INTO ACCOUNT
AS WE MOVE TOWARD THE MAY
REVISED BUDGET AND FINAL
ADOPTION IN JUNE. SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
STANDS ADJOURNED.